what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are covering the single greatest Kang
story of all time uh the one that
recently completed which is basically
retold the origin of Kang which is
called only myself left to conquer the
reason why I say it's a retelling or a
reworking of his origin is because
Kang's origin does exist in Marvel
Comics the problem is it's scattered all
over the damn place so you've got Marvel
two in one Comics you've got some Marvel
Premiere Comics you've got some Journey
in a mystery you've got Fantastic Four
some Avengers stuff right you have all
kinds of comics that all just sort of
feed into this great big huge origin of
King what this does is it consolidates
all the stuff that Marvel wants to keep
it changes the things they don't and
tells us how Kane the Conqueror became
Kane to conquer here's the problem this
story relies on you understanding
Rama Tut and immortus and iron lad and
all that stuff so
um we have to explain that before we get
into this now we do have a full-on
explanation about Kang but even then
people said it was still a bit confusing
so we're going to replace King with you
and you are going to imagine you are
king and we're gonna explain it that way
and if this can't solve it I don't know
what can't so here's the thing imagine
you right now living your life watching
this video and imagine that you suddenly
discovered the ability to travel back in
time right and you could do anything you
want to well I mean you're you're like
hey I'm gonna go back in time and
Conquer everything that's what I'm gonna
do I'm going to go back to the days of
ancient Egypt I'm gonna change my name
and I'm going to conquer all of
existence so you go all the way back to
the days of ancient Egypt and you start
calling yourself ramata and because of
your technological advancement you're
literally taking technology as it exists
right now back then let me tell you
something you show up there with an ink
pen you're gonna blow the minds of the
people in ancient Egypt right they're
they're gonna free they're gonna think
you're God right like they're not going
to know how to process that information
let alone if you took back something
like a computer which you couldn't use
or a notepad or something along those
lines right just technology that they
hadn't even considered yet so you go
back in time you change your name to
Rama Tut you rule that for for a
particular period of time now somebody
here in the present day doesn't matter
who it is realizes what you're doing
they go back in time and they basically
chase you out of ancient Egypt right
they're like you don't need to be here
uh you're a bad guy in the confines of
the comics it's the Fantastic Four let's
say whoever this person is they
basically fight you they overpower you
and you're forced to flee otherwise
you're going to die so your intention is
to say okay fine look I had the ability
to time travel I can go anywhere I want
to I mean I'm not just gonna quit after
being beat once right it's like the
dating game right try try again and so
you're like okay I'm gonna go back to
2022 and I'm gonna concoct a new plan on
how to conquer the past but along along
the way back along your journey back
here suddenly you end up in limbo and
you're just like okay what is this place
right and you explore the whole area you
start looking around you come across
technology different things like that
now while you're here in limbo it allows
you to look at the entire time stream
past present future the distant future
so you could literally watch your life
unfold from the realm of limbo and what
you do is you come to this realization
you're inevitably going to become a
villain that's a problem not only are
you going to become a villain now
there's an infinite number of universes
out there where you took different paths
and did different things and caused
different problems and maybe you form a
whole Council of yourself right like
literally hundreds of you who all meet
together occasionally and do some crazy
stuff and so what this does is it leads
to to you as you exist in limbo saying
okay I don't want to become my villain
itself I don't want to become that
villain version of me so I'm gonna stay
here and I'm gonna do everything I can
to work against myself here's the
problem what you have here is a
situation where you will inevitably have
to end up going back and becoming that
villainous version of yourself because
you exist right it's a paradox that
villainous version of yourself went back
into the past and became Rama Tut which
led you on your journey to where you are
right now calling yourself immortus
which means you know that's inevitably
going to happen no matter what you do
that's the future that's guaranteed for
you so what you're doing is trying to
work to keep that from happening now
let's move away from that version of
yourself right you're just kind of out
there doing your thing now let's say
that this future version of yourself in
the 31st Century as you're there you
come to this realization people are
going to work against me and it's
entirely possible that even even me even
even I myself may not become this
version of myself that's entirely
possible I may not I may lose the
ability to time travel or may never gain
the ability to time travel maybe I
decide to go to Burger King instead of
McDonald's and that shifts up everything
right so now I don't have the ability to
time travel any number of things could
happen that could that could prevent
that so what I need to do is I need to
go into the past and I need to meet with
my younger self and I need to make sure
that my younger self does all the things
that they're supposed to do so that I
can exist and so you do that you go back
back and you meet with your younger self
and you basically tell your younger self
look I'm the guy you're going to become
and so here's what you got to do right
you gotta you gotta do this thing you
got to do all these different things
over the course of time and if you don't
you're never going to become Meek well
your younger self looks at you and says
well I don't want to be you but I have
no desire to become you right you're a
dick like I don't want to be you at all
so I'm going to do everything I possibly
can not to become you and so as a result
you've made an enemy out of your younger
self now for our explanation here with
Kane the conquer when you went back in
time and became a ruler of Egypt that's
ramatut that's Kane the conquer becoming
rheumatoid when you ended up going to
limbo and started calling yourself
immortus that was Kane the conquer and
in the future when you go into the past
and meet with your younger self to try
to get your younger self to ensure they
become you that's iron lad that's how
all those things work together having
said that I don't know how else to
explain it besides that if that can't
explain Kane the Conqueror for you
nothing can either that or I'm just that
bad at it having said all that spent the
last six minutes explaining that let's
get into the comic the reason why you
guys are here if I haven't lost half of
you already so here's the thing what
this does is it initially picks up with
Nathaniel Richards in the 31st century
and what he says here is he says life at
this point in time really just kind of
sucks it's very very drab and very very
boring he says by the time he'd reached
the age of 18 he had conquered nothing
that his world was a Utopia of pleasure
and entertainment that is so-called
Bettors called it post-scarcity he
called it boring a Utopia to be sure
where 10 year olds could Master Advanced
robotics where a boy could have his
throat cut by bullies and recover in a
matter of months which is actually what
happened to him but it was also a place
where time seemed to stop that it was
the end of History a meaningless
procession of tepid moments a countdown
to nothing that while this Utopia is
beneficial for society as a whole in the
sense that nobody wants for anything
there is truth to the statement conflict
is in one way what gives people purpose
but is also what drives them to become
better that if people reach a point
where there is no conflict where there's
no struggling or no suffering or no pain
nobody will have a reason to improve
themselves because everybody will have
everything that they want and in the
face of that what you would likely run
into is a situation of stagnation now
whether that would happen in the real
world or not I have no idea but it's
what happened to Silver Surfers planet
is what happened to the people of Zin
law they stop focusing on religion
started focusing on science they
explored everything there was to explore
in the universe they cured every illness
they could possibly plague their people
they understood everything perfectly and
suddenly there was no more reason to
live because they had it all figured out
they had the answer to everything the
purpose behind life simply ceased to
exist and so what you end up getting is
basically Nathaniel who goes on this
kind of personal Quest where he
literally just starts traveling to these
old places that had long since been
forgotten and in a lot of ways we're
kind of off limits to the average person
but what he longed for was Adventure
what he longed for was the this kind of
bygone age you know in an era that he
was nostalgic for this despite the fact
that he never lived in it he was kind of
looking to this time when there were
straight up Heroes and there were
straight up villains all that kind of
stuff Fantastic Four Doctor Doom The
Avengers whoever in the hell else they
happen to be fighting all kinds of
things and so what he ends up doing and
going to this Museum he actually ends up
stumbling across a doom bot and that's
kind of the crazy thing is because
remember Dr Doom by this point is long
since dead and it's kind of a crazy
thing because one of the big questions
people have when it comes to Nathaniel
Richards is who is he related to because
Marvel's played it both ways they've
said that Nathaniel Richards is
descended from Victor Von Doom but
they've also said Nathaniel Richards is
is descended from Reed Richards well
maybe not necessarily said that but it's
kind of been sort of alluded to over the
years and so that's kind of a funny
thing because contextually we kind of
get an answer here that when this
doombot activates because it's just one
of the creations of Victor Von Doom
designed to stand the test of time when
it activates and starts attacking him
then of course this leads to King the
Conqueror showing up hang as we know him
showing up here destroying the a doombot
and then of course the kid saying like
who in the world are you right like you
need to answer me I am descended from
and then of course the whole thing gets
cut off now that's where contextually we
could argue that he is descended from
Victor Von do the problem here is that
if he was it's very likely that doombot
would have obeyed him when he told the
doombot to stop so again it's one of
those things where we kind of get an
answer and we kind of don't models never
really solidified it and to be honest
with you guys I don't think they ever
will I don't think Marvel will ever give
us a definitive answer as to whether or
not Kang is the the you know progeny or
the descendant of Reed or Victor I don't
think we'll ever get an answer but it's
kind of a cool thing there is because
ultimately where the two of them have
this kind of conversation came the
Conqueror approaches this from saying
like your voice is embarrassing right
like there is no easier place to lie
than in the pages of a book you'll learn
to trust only first-hand sources though
I suppose compared to the gruel that's
been that you've been raised on in this
place this would appear to be a Feast so
let me ask you would you rather read
history or would you rather make history
and so the Allure of this adventure the
Allure of being able to actually go and
live these Adventures that he'd spent so
much time reading about that's what
draws the interest of Nathaniel Richards
and so at the end you know of course in
this conversation Nathaniel's like are
you kidding me right like that's the
only thing I want this world is so thin
it's like there's absolutely nothing
here and I want everything and so the
response of King is good that means
you're ready so now ask your question
again but ask it with conviction and the
kid says who are you and this guy you
know King responds and says it's I've
been called a thousand things right ten
thousand different names by all these
different worlds that I've conquered and
so on and so forth like I've been called
a conqueror I've been called The Eternal
the god Pharaoh Rama Tut The Time Keeper
immortus but despite all of them there's
only one name that truly Rings true and
that's King the Conqueror and so he says
in the beginning before all of it I was
you and so it's an amazing conversation
that happens here because he says
through this doorway is an infinite
number of times and worlds eras that
sing my name and praise planets that
worship me but to earn those I have
known loss defeat and frustration he
says I would save you that trauma and
all of that time join me and own the
mysteries of the cosmos join me and
become king the Conqueror and so in the
end it doesn't take a whole lot to
convince Nathaniel the world he's in is
so boring and it's so basic and it's so
simple that in the end he's like
absolutely right so he immediately joins
him on this Quest and what happens the
first stop is King takes him to 65
million years before Common Era the age
of the dinosaurs specifically one year
before the asteroid hits that wipes out
all the dinosaurs on earth and what Kane
says is like this is your first lesson
right time means nothing to kink like
yes I'm dropping you off here and yes
you have a year to become you but you
think that way because your thing
thinking two-dimensionally in a
three-dimensional world right like it's
it's a it's an interesting concept right
like people trying to make it in the
real world how do I succeed become
successful and wealthy in the real world
I know by working for someone else and
that's not true it's thinking
two-dimensionally in a three-dimensional
world you have to think outside the box
what can you do on your own that can
make you better absent the influence and
the need of other individuals out there
can you build a world for yourself or
are you satisfied in living in someone
else's and so that's the cool thing here
is because what Kang says and this is
one of the most important things that he
says it's easy to overlook it's easy to
not take seriously but one of the things
he says is he says many of my memories
are fogged by the ways of time centuries
of conflicting timelines playing tricks
in my head but I remember every one of
those first days with Clarity my lessons
began with survival strengthening my
body and mind where I could not
strengthen it myself Kang did so for me
now the reason why this matters and this
kind of goes back to our initial
explanation of why it was so necessary
involving immortus and andromatot and
all those different guys is because
whenever Kang went back in time and
fashioned a life for himself he became
that person he became that person that
he was pretending to be and so here's
what I want you to do right in order to
truly understand how this impacts Hank
here's what I want you to do I want you
to put in the comments or at least tell
me what did you have for dinner on
January 26
2019. if you can't tell me and if you
did tell me I would probably just think
you were lying just making something up
in order to be like yep I remember
everything no nobody remembers that that
singular moment there right now that's a
couple years ago and if I if I change
that question and said what'd you have
for dinner on Monday last week you'd be
able to give me a much better guess but
instead of this being two years ago
let's pretend it's ten thousand years
ago and a life that you lived for 90
years that's what Kane contends with
that's the issue that he has and that's
why often times in comics you'll see
Kang come across immortus or iron lad or
something like that and it'll almost be
like their completely different people
because why all standards the
measurement they basically are right
like imagine you went back in time 50
years and lived out an entire life and
then at the end of that life came back
to the Modern Age and then just lived
for another Thousand Years here after a
while you wouldn't really even remember
what that what that lifetime was like
when you went back 50 years ago but it
does exist and that version of yourself
is there so it's just one of those those
weird and interesting things about
kangits why you do have different
variations of himself but they're also
starkly different in the end though this
cycle always continues right it's like
Battlestar Galactica all of this has
happened before and all of this will
happen again that Kang always becomes
king and King always goes and finds his
younger self and always leads his
younger self to become king the
exception is Iron Lab but at the end of
the day the argument still stands that
iron lad will inevitably become king the
Conqueror so it's one of these things
where he talks about whenever he says
king showed me this just imagine this
cycle as it happens right now except
this young Nathaniel Richards grows up
to be this adult King and this adult
Kang is basically reliving or retelling
his experiences as you see them here
he's basically recalling the life that
we're gonna see this young Nathaniel
Richards live over the course of this
comic it's very meta textual but that's
why it's so loopy that's why it goes in
circles and cycles and so that's why as
as young Nathaniel is talking about all
this he says Kane showed me our life as
a pharaoh of Egypt and taught me its
lesson and he laid bare the rules of
time which lit my mind Ablaze he says
his lessons were brutal and he says I
was proud when I overcame them as I was
proud of what we would build together he
taught me to shoot he taught me to kill
he taught me that a plan no matter how
meticulous only serves to make you weak
he forced me just as he promised but as
I was forged so did I Glimpse the flaws
in the iron that made my teacher now
this is an important thing because one
of the things that you usually see when
it comes to Kane the Conqueror is him
showing up on the scene doing some stuff
all kinds of Hell unleashing conflict
unfolding and that's basically it you
never really get to see the
interpersonal side of Ken the part of
Kang that struggles because one of the
things he says is he says that once Kane
got so drunk that he could barely stand
and he took me to a far-off world where
he cried in the shadows as a woman died
he said one word then was silent for
days that word being ravana right of
course ravana rensslayer now the thing
of the thing about this the reason why
it matters is because ravana rensslayer
was the love interest of Kane the
Conqueror and she died right King's life
literally fell apart when that happened
in fact the way that Marvel wrote that
it was almost kind of a question of will
King ever recover from this it was
focusing on that interpersonal side but
you don't really see it all that often
and of course even Kang made Nathaniel
swear he would never bring it up right
like he would never mention it or
anything along those lines and so what
happens as he goes through this period
right again back in the 65 million years
that he's here as he goes through all of
that of course he ends up facing off
against you know some Tyrannosaurus Rex
which is awesome black acid with some
with a massive gun
literally blows this thing's head off
and what he says is this is this is
where things are really really
fascinating and he says he would love to
say that in the aftermath of killing
this T-Rex that he feasted on dinosaur
meat for days and he sharpened its teeth
into knives right that he somehow honed
his skills became this brutal Warrior
that could live off the land but he says
that never happened and the reason why
is because by the time I killed this
thing all I saw was her all I saw was
this one person right this One Singular
individual and like that she had the
complete and total attention of Hank he
never had a chance right Nathaniel was
just smitten for this woman and what was
more interesting than this is that in
the society that he came from physical
touch didn't happen you never physically
touched people it was always done as a
kind of synthesis right a kind of uh you
know barrier between you and somebody
else is a way to like prevent disease
illness different things like that and
so for the first real time in his life
he's experiencing tactile contact with
an another human being more so than that
he's experiencing love he's experiencing
desire he's having all these feelings
that he's never quite really been
through before and so having this kind
of experience with her in a lot of ways
I wouldn't go as far as to say she's in
love with him and I would even go as far
as to say he's not necessarily in love
with her if anything it's more passing
curiosity now that will change that will
inevitably change but of course she kind
of invites him to her tribe and so of
course he ends up basically chasing her
down following her to that location and
he's taken before the people here now
what's kind of baffling is that from
Nathaniel Richard's perspective there
shouldn't be any human beings here now I
use that based on the real world right
that like uh primitive human beings
appeared maybe something around 300 000
years ago that the anatomical version of
ourselves that exists now is probably
about 200 000 years ago and then over
time our minds just progress to where we
are right now uh in Marvel Comics one
thing to know is that when it comes to
the evolution of the human race we're
not really given anything before the
arrival of the Celeste it's like even in
Marvel Comics they don't do that the
closest that we ever really got in terms
of those early days is maybe a little
bit of discussion about proto-mutants uh
with Gabriel Shepard the old stories
with uh not really old story I guess
they are now Jesus I'm old 20-something
year old stories 21 year old stories by
Grant Morrison
with new X-Men she she's my mold
Christ
in any event
um we're not really given an actual
origin point for when Modern Man first
appeared in Marvel Comics so I can
almost guarantee though it wasn't 65
million years ago and this race as is
being told right this girl Addie and and
her race we're not really given any
information so we don't really know if
like their time displaced or anything
like that they certainly don't act like
it but Nathaniel is brought before the
lasting piece which is basically their
Elder right the the leader of the tribe
who kind of gives us this perception
that he knows who Nathaniel Richards is
going to become but he doesn't know he's
going to become king if anything is more
of his actions that demonstrate who he
is as a person the fact that he saved
Addy's life from a dinosaur the fact
that he killed the dinosaur basically
shows that he is a person of conviction
and strength and as a result he's
brought into the tribe and honored as a
Warrior by basically being given face
paint now the other part of this is that
the tribe again because they're
primitive relies on you know prophecies
from the stars and different things like
that so they're very much given to
Superstition right this kind of a thing
and of course according to the
prophecies handed down from the elders
you know presumably the ones that came
before the lasting peace and by the
lasting piece himself they're doomed to
be destroyed by a star right by like
literally a meteor crashing into Earth
they don't really know that's what it is
but that's basically what it is and so
the thing about this is that the
Nathaniel flees to Cain the Conqueror
and says we have the ability to
manipulate time Neil time does not
matter to us so let's just take them
somewhere else let's take them to a
future right we can just snatch them up
while they're sleeping or whatever it is
but we can take them to you know some
period when the earth is habitable again
and then go from there now this is one
of the most important things that goes
on with this new origin of Kane the
Conqueror Kane the conqueror's concern
is not a disruption of the time streak
the reality is that it would right most
likely the destruction of this race
serves some purpose along the timeline
right their bones are discovered or
something like that somebody makes some
kind of a discovery which leads them
down some path where they do some things
and then that leads to them becoming a
superhero and change changes the entire
course of stuff who knows but regardless
like you can't necessarily meddle with
the time stream in that way and so what
happens here is that when Nathaniel runs
to King and asks like are you awake the
response of Kang is that no it is you
who's not awake right your you dream the
naive dreams of Heroes the romance of
Alexander the purity of Steve Rogers you
will unlearn this sentimentality never
disappear from my sight again you will
do as you are ordered you will learn the
lessons I teach and never disregard them
and above all else you will wipe that
pathetic paint off of your face and the
response of Nathaniel is no that's not
going to happen and so as an answer to
this King simply says I do not make
requests right you are here by my design
and shall behave by my design your
future lies in the balance heed me or be
doomed to a life of failure of rot and
Toil and insignificance and that's when
Nathaniel's like but that's the point
you're the one who's failed you talk
endlessly about conquest and Glory but
you're just a drunk who makes me
memorize his defeats how Doom tricked
you at the fall of Manhattan how the
Fantastic Four laid you low in the Sands
of Egypt and so this is kind of back and
forth argument and in the end Nathaniel
says my life is my own it's out there
living on without me and the people of
that tribe we can save them from the
coming cataclysm if time means nothing
to us then why can't I use it to save
the first and last in this blasted world
and in the end the response of Kang is
you believe that because you're in love
and it's that love that makes you weak
it's that love that takes away any
measure of strength that you can have
that's the stance that King has his
sentimentality the fact that he's
experienced love and kindness and
romance he sees that as a weakness he
sees it as the thing that it always held
him back that if he could go back in
time and he could alter that younger
version of himself so that he didn't
experience love that that sentimentality
was stamped out of him then those
weaknesses would never come to fruition
in those moments when he hesitated
instead of killing the Fantastic Four
due to some sentimentality or some
statement made by Reed or Susan or
something like that right like who's
going to take care of our children that
if that sentimentality wasn't there he
would have pulled the trigger without
hesitation that cruelty would have
dominated and so in order to try to
demonstrate this he dragged Nathaniel to
the camp when Nathaniel says I will save
them the response of King is no boy you
did not and opens fire on the place just
incinerates kills everybody there every
single person dies right they're
completely and totally killed and
Nathaniel can do nothing more than just
sit there and watch now this is hugely
important because what he says is it was
then that I understood though I had
crossed the fabric of space and time I
had never left my cage at all it was
then that I saw the cage was King and so
what he did is he basically made this
promise to himself that he wouldn't
become king he says and so for the final
months of the Cretaceous I pretended to
stop study that which king instructed
while secretly I studied the lock how
the mention of ravana might drive my
Jailer to drink how a few herbs might
intoxicate a glass of wine how the armor
that had opened the way might be mine to
command I'd rarely been as tempted as I
was in that moment to take the
inevitable into my own hands but his
words echoed in my ear time would
conquer all my enemies if only I could
Master it and so literally it almost
appears on the surface this is how King
becomes iron lad but that doesn't
necessarily seem to be the case instead
as this meteor comes crashing down into
the world with the intention of
destroying it and basically leading to
the end of all things he ultimately ends
up walking away travels through a time
portal and when he does he finds himself
in the realm of Rama Tut what this does
is this takes place during the era of
what is essentially Rama Tut now that's
where things get a little murky because
when he shows up here is essentially a
giant battle take taking place now this
battle is between ramu Tut and somebody
else who we'll talk about here in a
little bit but on this battlefield is
effectively a Moon Knight now one of the
reasons why Colin Kelly is able to pull
this off is because as you guys know
just from the history of Moon Knight and
Marvel Comics it wasn't really until
March Specter was taken to the Statue of
konshu that the world got its first Moon
knife over the years and really when I
say over the years I mean more recently
in Marvel Comics that's been changed but
it's kind of been a big red con to
essentially say there have been
different avatars of konshu on Earth in
the form of a Moon Knight that came
before Mark Spector and it's not
uncommon for Marvel to do that for years
for example Danny Rand was the only Iron
Fist and then we got Orson Randall who
was the iron fist before Danny Rand and
there were a whole bunch of iron fists
before Orson Randall it had just gone on
that way the idea of there being Moon
Knights that took place or existed
before Mark Specter that was largely the
result of Jason Aaron and his run on
Avengers specifically with Avengers 1
million so basically this idea that
there was an Avengers team that exists
said one million years before the modern
era it was largely composed of big Heavy
Hitters so like Odin the original
Phoenix Force as it existed on Earth the
first star brand the first Iron Fist the
first black panther different things
along those lines just uh kind of giving
us these different stories sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't when it comes
to Moon Knight what you get here is
basically this version that pops up now
there isn't a whole lot of explanation
given here initially instead what ends
up happening is that this person is told
or at least Nathaniel's told by this
Moon Knight you are called by the moon
and initially when Nathaniel chases this
Moon Knight down trying to figure out
who they are or where they're going or
how all this is working that the only
thing he's really told is that the voice
of the Knight speaks only truth a hero
from Beyond time comes soon from the sky
to restore the ancient ways and end The
Pretenders Reign now this is one of the
things that we have to talk about here
is the nature of Rama Tut and why it is
that this version of Moon Knight differs
from Mark Spector so when it comes to
Rama taught one of the things that we've
talked about before is that King the
Conqueror in his initial attempt for
Conquest had gone all the way back to
ancient Egypt and basically seized
control and because of the fact that he
had come from the 31st Century as has
been stated by different people and in
different ways that sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic and so Kane the conquerors
showing up here with advanced technology
as far as the ancient Egyptians were
concerned he was a God right they were
like this guy's just capable of
incredible things this is insane right
obviously this person is a God now
pharaohs in the time of ancient Egypt
were largely considered to be avatars of
God of specifically raw or other other
individuals on Earth but they were
considered Divine in nature and so
because of that Kane kind of fit very
nicely into how Egyptians perceived
people uh specifically pharaohs and the
idea of magic and divine powers and so
that's why he sees control here now one
of the things to know is that konshu and
the various gods that existed had long
since existed here by and large konshu
doesn't really care what goes on on
Earth he's got his own scheme and his
own motivation one of the things that's
been recently established especially
during
um oh my God Jeff lemir's run on on moon
night is that konshu seeks to basically
find a vessel for himself to basically
rule the world hence the reason why he
had manipulated Mark Spector and his
disassociative identity disorder in
order to hollow him out quote unquote
and turn him into a vessel that konshu
could inhabit and then rule the world so
konchu and the various other Egyptian
gods don't necessarily concern
themselves with the idea that like King
the conquerors come from the future to
the Past in order to rule ancient Egypt
but one of the other things to notice
here is that this version of Moon Knight
wholly believes in what kanchu told them
and not to sound too Brusque about it
but the reason why is because they just
don't know any better by the time Mark
Spector had become Moon Knight people
were more intelligent they were more
capable and they were more aware of how
the world exists so the idea of gods and
things like that had largely Fallen away
this takes place during that era to a
degree before the third Celestial host
where you basically had the celestial
showing up until telling the various
Gods of Earth not to intervene in the
Affairs of mortal men it kind of follow
Falls during that that bit of a murky
period we can largely assume that maybe
that's already happened but whatever it
is the influence of gods and goddesses
on Humanity still holds strong and
that's why this person who became Moon
Knight hears the voice of konchu and
takes it as an absolute truth because by
the time Mark Spector came around in the
20th century the idea of people
believing in Gods sure it was there but
they didn't believe it with the same
veracity right they didn't believe it
with the same absolute belief system it
was like you know people believed in the
idea of God because they were more
afraid of the consequences of not
believing than the actual benefit of
believing if there is one and so as the
two of them talk when it comes to
Nathaniel remember he knows the entire
history of Earth and so what he says and
he says far be it for me to argue with
my savior but Rama taught isn't someone
you can just hope to overthrow trust me
I've studied him for years and the
response to this person is he's Enslaved
the entirety of creation now as somebody
who's never left Egypt as far as they're
concerned Egypt is all of creation and
the the influence of of Rama Tut just
stretches into Infinity now of course
that's not the case and Nathaniel says
it's only really Egypt but like that's
plenty of stuff to rule he says it's his
War Machine against my broken suit of
armor I'm sorry lady but I'm not the
hero that you're looking for you're
thinking of Reed Richards now the reason
why this matters and I love that Colin
Kelly did this is because in the
original story when Rama taught first
appeared in in Marvel Comics The
Fantastic Four traveled back to Egypt
defeated Rama's Hut and forced him to
travel back to his timeline right they
defeated that version of King now again
as we discussed along the way back to
his timeline he ended up in the true
limbo became a mortise and then there's
kind of a splinter timeline where he
ended up going back and becoming King
but the the reality here is that what
you're doing or at least what Colin
Kelly's doing is he's basically keeping
the continuity of the history of Rama
Tut intact but adding to it which is a
really cool thing right that's a pretty
beneficial thing and a very important
thing but what goes on here is
ultimately Nathaniel is taken to the
temple of can't you and is basically
told like talk to talk to konshu itself
and find out if there's any real truth
here the reality though is that
Nathaniel doesn't really believe in Gods
I mean he knows that they've existed but
they're not all powerful beings they
don't really exist in the capacity of
the way that this this Moon Knight
believes they do that they are just
people that are out there and they can
be killed and so as a result of that
Nathaniel really views God as more of
just really powerful beings as opposed
to these Divine individuals beyond the
understanding of humanity and with a
power that just simply can't be matched
the only real God that exists out there
in Marvel Comics in that capacity is the
one above all everybody else can just be
killed it just takes differing levels of
power to do it the Living Tribunal was
killed by the beyonders the other Cosmic
entities as well and the different
Cosmic entities have been destroyed by
different beings depending on what era
of comics you're talking about if you're
looking at Al Ewing's ultimates that the
uh that eternity was basically defeated
and not really killed but overpowered by
like the first firmament right the
sentient of the first universe so it
gets a little meta and it gets a little
wonky but as the two of them continue
talking what ends up going on is that
this person reveals their identity to
Nathaniel Richards and we end up finding
out this Moon Knight is actually ravana
rensslayer now here's the thing to
understand here and this is why I say
from this point going forward the entire
history of ravana rensslayer is going to
be completely Rewritten or at least her
origin is going to be completely
Rewritten the original origin of ravana
rinselayer is she's from the 40th
century and that you ended up having a
time where Kane the Conqueror had
arrived there but ultimately spared the
place because he was in love with her
and then it was a kind of love-hate
relationship where they loved each other
then they hated each other she killed
him a couple times
they were just one of those things there
was literally a point where she
resurrected him just to kill him it's
kind of nuts right it was that level of
hate and disdain but it was very much a
love hate if anything a passionate
relationship between the two what it
looks like Colin Kelly's doing is
reworking the entirety of that by
introducing ravana rensslayer here and
saying she is a Moon Knight and then
presenting her Us in this way what it
looks like is this is where ravana
rensslayer starts this is where her
origin begins instead of it being in the
40th Century she was just a person in
Egypt and ended up becoming a host for
konshu as the first Moon Knight or one
of the Moon Knights presumably the
second moon night after Avengers 1
million and she just kind of goes
forward from there but again things will
be explained as time effectively goes on
because we'll actually see different
versions of her in different points in
time across this story so it'll be a
little murky to a degree not gonna lie a
little ambiguous there but at the end of
the day she presents herself as a person
that wholeheartedly believes in the idea
of konshu and what ends up happening is
Nathaniel kind of says I do not believe
in Gods in my life of Conquest I have
crushed countless Divine skulls in my
hands but even before I saw fear in the
eyes of the god of thunder and yet he
recalls those thoughts by Kang never
love and he says in that place my mind
ran clear the past the future like a
river of blood from my mind to King's
neurokinetic armor time in memory
recourse through my veins I swore that I
would be the hero she saw in me I swore
to tear him down as she says in the
shadow of a dead God I took my revenge
and cast it in iron and so what this
says and this isn't necessarily
something that's absolutely solidified
in the modern era what this says is that
this younger version of Kang basically
becomes the first Iron lad now I say
that as if there's more than one iron
light I mean I guess technically there
kind of is but not necessarily the
reality here is that in the end it is
okay right so this kind of origin still
Rings true right the origin of King but
what one of the things to know is that
in the old school or not really old
school but in the Young Avengers stories
that the idea of iron lad was basically
a younger version of Kang that didn't
want to become king and did everything
he could not to become king but in the
end every origin of everybody stems from
Kang in the 30th and 31st centuries and
so because of that they are all destined
to become king eventually immortus goes
on to become king iron lad goes on to
become king everybody originates from
Kang because he was a guy that basically
went back in time and initially started
it all and that's why if you look at
characters like Kane the Conqueror or
even like uh reverse flash eobard Thon
in DC Comics the reason why they're
basically indestructible in the sense
that you can never truly kill them is
because they effectively exist
simultaneously at different points in
time and so because they exist at
different points in time they can always
reappear at any point in time so imagine
you for example traveled back to I don't
know like the first century right just
some arbitrary point in time uh you
exist in the first century but because
we have Branch universe theory there's
also a reality or a timeline where you
never travel back in time and so if
somebody were to go to that point where
you quote unquote went back in time uh
and they stopped you the moment before
you did and they killed you then what
that would mean is you would still exist
in the first century you would still be
there instead there is a branch universe
that exists out there now where you died
before you could go back in time so you
could never truly kill that person it's
one of those things where in in Marvel
and even DC Comics once a person learns
the ability to travel through the time
stream the instant they make their first
attempt or their first travel through
time they can never truly be destroyed
now they can always just reappear at any
point in time so it's really kind of
murky and it's really it's very very
ambiguous and I know when it comes to
time travel it can be a little confusing
but it's essentially a way to unlock
immortality using technological means
but the result of this is that as Iron
Lab really the first time he becomes
this character he basically ends up
helping the forces of of Moon Knight and
this what seems to be this Rebel faction
facing off against Rama Tut and trying
to bring down his Rule now the reality
of this and what's really really cool is
that in these various battles they're a
part of there is a larger Force pulling
the strings when it comes to these
forces that are trying to destroy or
bring down Kane to conquer we'll get to
them here in a second although I imagine
some of you guys have already guessed
who that person is one of the greatest
characters of all time
[Music]
whom I absolutely love uh but one of the
things to know is that as these battles
are fought that it's really more of a
series of battles as part of a
continuous war and as you know battles
end and so in these bits of lulls
there's a very deep and personal
connection that's formed between
Nathaniel and ravana renssler and it's
kind of interesting because she asked
the question in the place that you come
from is this place remembered and he
says in the time that I come from
everything is remembered imperfectly and
through the lens of the victors perhaps
but remembered all the same that was the
problem when everything's been done
before you what can your life possibly
be worth but I knew I was destined for
more even before Kane came to visit me I
knew and the response to ravana is I
have never known a life without Destiny
I remember nothing before it my parents
were the will of konshu and they have
long ago vanished into the sunlight of
my memory if they were ever there at all
and the response here is that Nathaniel
asks did he give you your name your God
and her response is no my name has
always been but he did give me yours and
that's when she says like I was told you
were coming here but in this moment he
recalls the words that King had spoken
to him when he was effectively trying to
rid him of weakness and saying never
love lest you be conquered but the
thought of Nathanael here is but he knew
nothing of love I was absolutely sure he
was a creature of hate when you are
young it is so hard to see that one is
only born from the other that without
love to inspire it hate is simply just
rage anger can be conquered by calm but
like its pathetic cousin regret hatred
just feeds it makes one ruthless it
drives the preparation of armories and
the shattering of centuries it
intertwines with the power of a parasite
around the brainstem love makes one
blind as hatred makes one see and it is
in that way that we fell under his eye
what Nathaniel's really saying here is
that when it comes to the ideas of love
and hate they really are intertwined
Kang hates the person he became because
he experienced love because he fell in
love with ravana rensslayer and he saw
that idea of love as the thing that made
him weak that rage is directionless Rage
has no real drive or ambition as a thing
that exists as a byproduct of
experiences things that have maybe
happened to you but it's not necessarily
born in love but love is is an intensely
positive emotion and I would argue the
most positive emotion hate can be born
out of love which drives you to the most
negative emotion the reality here is
that he sees Kang as becoming the person
he did because he experienced love but
in his desire to refuse to become king
he Embraces love he seeks love and in
fact that's where he and ravana
rensslayer effectively fall in love now
again this is why I say this new origin
of ravana rinselayer is a little
ambiguous here because the answer she
gives Nathaniel on her origin are cloak
and dagger at best right and it may just
be smoke and mirrors she's like well
I've always had my name maybe it's a
name that was given me by my parents but
I don't really even know if my parents
existed anymore right their memory the
memory of them is basically gone and
it's one of those weird things because
you would think that for a person her
age which you know just going on the way
she's drawn looks to be maybe in her
late 20s early 30s she would very
definitely remember her parents but the
idea here is that potentially her
parents may have died and when she was
at a very young age in which case it may
be one of those things where her memory
just doesn't really recall a lot of her
parents because she was so young when
they died there's no definitive answers
given here but you could look at it from
a different perspective and say she's
very much like Rama Tut she basically
came here at some past point in time as
she came here from the future because of
all the different adventures in
escapades she'd gone on but at the end
of the day uh she's just Fallen the same
path as Rama Tut she doesn't remember a
whole lot about herself but what goes on
is that once the two of them were
captured and they're brought before Rama
Tut that initially Rama's HUD actually
ends up blasting uh ravana rinselayer
with what's known as the ultra diode Ray
and it's basically a weapon well used by
Kane the conquerors how he ensnared a
lot of the people under his service and
basically forces her into a position of
of being a subject right it takes away
her willpower and in fact that seemed to
be the way in which he was able to form
his initial higher counsel and then in
turn position himself as a god king now
the response of Nathaniel is of course
to lash out one part because he's in
love with her and two because he knows
that Rama Tut is King from a different
point in time now remember as time would
pass Kane the Conqueror in ramu Tut
would eventually become their own
distinct personalities but Rama Tut does
remember his his idea or remember him
being King at one point in time and so
that's why he he kind of recognizes
Nathaniel Richards to a degree and so
far as like iron lad different things
like that but he doesn't have any memory
of this sort of encounter taking place
because it's never happened before or at
least it doesn't seem to have happened
before one of the big issues is that
King's entire history is a Time Loop and
so seemingly this has happened before
it's just for whatever reason every time
feels like the first time which is kind
of weird I know it's we're never going
to go into that because it just seems
wonky it just seems really really meta
and honestly would just take too long to
explained up but at the end of the day
the Rama type really says like I have no
memory of this right a Divergent
timeline perhaps some kind of a variant
or a new Loop whatever it is what this
means is that killing you would no more
affect me than the destruction of an
alien son and the response to Nathaniel
is smart here he says but Rama Tut is a
footnote in our story barely even a
prologue you don't even know our true
name I would think very hard before you
execute me the throat you slit may very
well be your own that means Kane the
Conqueror will never come into existence
and if Kane the Conqueror never comes
into existence there's no one to come
back in time and to be you now the
reality here is that Colin Kelly is
jumping back and forth between a linear
timeline and Branch universe theory the
reality here is based on Marvel's Branch
universe theory if Rama taught were to
kill uh basically iron lad it wouldn't
make any difference it would have no
real involvement in any real capacity
whatsoever it would just be a thing that
happens and that would basically be it
uh that's kind of how that branch
universe theory concept Works in Marvel
Comics but at the end of the day what he
says is you know what you're absolutely
right here uh you know killing you is
too much of a risk however using you is
a great strategy because you're
technologically advanced you have access
to essentially all my resources and even
some of the resources that I don't have
access to so we'll turn you into a
servant instead of killing you and so by
blasting him we basically turns him into
what is in effect the first Scarlet
Centurion now one of the big differences
between this and Comics is they were
originally written is that when Kane the
Conqueror was on his way back to his
time stream he did end up arriving in
the modern era due to a Time storm and
encountered Dr Doom and their first
encounter and somewhat inspired by Dr
Doom's armor basically Kane got rid of
the Rama Tut guys and then basically
started calling himself a Scarlet
Centurion of course again that was
covered in what was covered in a few
different places it was like Avengers
annual number two God it was like
Captain America annual number 11. and I
want to say it was in Fantastic Four no
it wasn't it was a what if story I
remember the exact issue of the what if
story I think it was issue number four
yeah it was is what if issue number 29
that all this stuff was basically
explained and and whatnot but the thing
behind this is that giving us this
indication as the first Scarlet
Centurion what it does is it sets the
stage for the idea that in a lot of ways
came to conquer just kind of inspired
himself to become the people that he was
but making Nathaniel into Scala
Centurion he ends up leading the forces
of Kane the Conqueror albeit against his
will against the force that is
controlling all these individuals out
there that are fighting against the rule
of of ramatut and trying to conquer his
kingdom of course all of them being led
by apocalypse which I love now this is
one of the things where Colin Kelly is
basically kind of blowing off the old
Adventures of uh Cyclops in Phoenix
which is where you got the initial
origin of Apocalypse where basically he
was rising to power around the same time
that uh ramatut Was Defeated and the way
he's depicted in this comic he's already
in possession of celestial technology
that hadn't happened yet in the old
school story so basically it's Colin
Kelly kind of rewriting the history you
have apocalypse to a degree which is
fine the origin of Apocalypse I mean
it's there but I never really took it as
an absolute truth and it's one of those
things where anybody could rewrite it in
virtually any way and it's fine if they
did for the most part people don't
really care about apocalypse
before he became apocalypse they care
about him after he became apocalypse
because that's when he got awesome right
so it's cool to see him leading this
Force now of course with Apocalypse at
what is in effect the height of his
power because once he achieved this
level his power never really increased
he was just at this state for seemingly
thousands of years before the modern era
but the thing about this is that at this
point in time he's wildly powerful and
wildly capable but in the end the battle
is a pretty severe and extreme battle
and so what Nathaniel says it was is
that it was in those days that I first
knew War I learned the way a scream
sounds when it is someone's last and how
fear alone can stop a heartbeat even
before death love made me blind and so I
began to hate I saw the only path
forward my body was a prison my armor a
cage to escape King's power both needed
to be broken and he says and through the
pain I swore I will have revenge on King
I will have revenge on Kang and he's and
that's the thing he keeps saying to
motivate himself and that's the thing he
kept saying to remind himself now by the
time he gets back to the Citadel of King
where King is basically operating that's
when he sees the Fantastic Four fighting
against Kang and then ultimately pushing
him back to his timeline and of course
that's how his history kind of unfolds
the original Scarlet Centurion as we
initially saw him in the old Fantastic
Four comics and so on and so forth but
the reality here is he says that within
a day of ramatut's Escape into the time
stream his kingdom fell to chaos that
apocalypse took all he wished and burned
the remnants no record of ravana Rim
Slayer like a footprint in the Sands of
the desert she was scattered to time I
told myself a lie in those days none are
lost in the light of the moon but I knew
better than to believe it she was As
Dead As the God she served but Kang was
still alive and so that's why things are
a little murky here is because again
maybe ravana winslayer comes to the
Future she went to the Past she
basically forgot her own history and
believes she had always just existed
there and then became a Moon Knight it's
one of those things that we'll explore
as the story goes on but the Final Act
in basically trying to get back to his
time because in effect he doesn't really
have the same level of technology that
he used to have he's stuck in his
Scarlet Centurion suit is he goes to the
only person who has a level of power
that could get him through the time
stream he goes to apocalypse and he
simply says together we can destroy Kang
the Conqueror I was reading over the
comments of the previous videos after I
got back and I noticed that some of you
guys were a little confused in terms of
how the whole Kane the Conqueror thing
works and all that kind of stuff okay so
as you guys know when it comes to Marvel
Comics the main Marvel universe is Earth
616 right that's well established you
guys have all pretty much known that for
quite some time what you have is you do
have a Nathaniel Richards from earth616
but that is the Nathaniel Richards known
as the father of Reed Richard so if you
ever read Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four run that's Nathaniel right now he
does have time traveling escapades and
so on and so forth and he was part of
Kang War different things along those
lines but when you think of King the
Conqueror right Prime King if you want
to call him that the main Kane the
Conqueror who goes back in time and
fights the Avengers and all that kind of
stuff he comes from a reality called
Earth 6311. this story as it's being
told is basically the origin of King the
difference here is that unlike what a
lot of the stuff that you've read before
it's designed to basically rework his
origin slightly as well as massively
rework characters like Pravana
rensslayer and the reason for that is
because coming out of the Loki TV show
Bravada rensslayer is a very popular
character or at least pretty popular way
more than she ever was in the comics and
so there was a lot of confu fusion with
her character in the comics if Loki had
literally ended and said for more about
ravana run Slayer go read Marvel Comics
as she exists right now it would confuse
the piss out of people they would have
no idea where to start or which version
of her it is or anything like that it
was it was just it was a massively
complicated thing right she was just
kind of thrown in there with a time
traveling escapades of Kang and there
was no real explanation given insofar as
how it all ties together this story
corrects that the other part of that is
that where this story focused on
answering the question this idea that
when Kane to conquer was a teenager some
future version of himself just showed up
and said I'm gonna turn you into me that
we're aided focused on younger Kang try
not to become his older self this video
right here is where everything begins to
shift so in the last video that we
covered we had basically talked about
how there was a it was really younger
King ending up in ancient Egypt and
coming across Rama Tut who as you guys
know was Kane the Conqueror going back
to ancient Egypt and then basically
trying to rule there and then conquer
the Earth from that point going forward
ultimately though there was a great big
war taking place between uh Kane the
conquer and apocalypse and so as a
result of that what you ended up having
was younger King who basically Allied
himself with what appeared to be ravana
rensslayer in ancient Egypt and then in
turn helping uh helping apocalypse fend
off and really defeat the forces of
ramatud of course with King basically
fleeing back to his present after being
defeated by The Fantastic Four who had
time travel to that time period again we
had covered more of that in the video so
if that's a little confusing to you I
invite you to go back and check out that
video the thing about it is that after
that whole conflict is ended right that
adult Kang fled back to his own time and
all you're left with is younger Kang
here in that whole series of events that
whole Calamity ravana rinselayer had
effectively died and so as a result of
that because ravana rensslayer it
basically appeared intermittently
throughout the time stream and really
defied anything regarding like the laws
of Aging or anything like that and no
explanation has been given yet which we
will we'll get an explanation on that um
basically you have young Kang who's in
love with Pravana rinselayer he has a
vendetta against his old herself and
then he also wants to find a way to save
ravana so what he ends up doing is
making a deal with Apocalypse Now as you
guys know apocalypse as a villain this
guy's nothing if not just beholden to
Evolution right the Guy believes in
Social Darwin isn't Only the strongest
deserve to survive it's one of the
reasons why apocalypse is a little
hypocritical in some ways on one hand
he'll make these grandiose speeches
about how Evolution will have its do and
only those who who are able to deal with
you know strengthen and and show how
capable they are are the ones who
deserve to live all the while he
basically used the techno-organic virus
as it was given to him by cable albeit
inadvertently to interface with
Celestial technology and Grant himself
all these Powers so if he was really
living up to his own belief system he
never would have done that he would have
just used whatever Powers had been
naturally given to him to find some way
to be a conqueror so basically it's a
long way for me to say that when it
comes to his life philosophy apocalypse
is foolish so the thing about this is
that what he does is he tells Nathaniel
like I will give you the ability to
travel forward in time right to travel
to you know your future or whatever time
period you need to go to but you will
not do it using some kind of time
machine or anything like that you will
do it at the whims and wants of time
herself and so instead of him just being
given the ability to travel into the
future by way of some sort of machine or
something like that he's actually
encased in a sarcophagus and left there
for like thousands of years where he
just kind of goes forward right
literally just sitting there in this
case now the thing about it is that that
Kang doesn't really say that this is any
kind of a torture I mean psychologically
it is to a degree but in order to keep
himself from going insane he steals
himself right he says time is a thing to
be conquered that was the edge of King's
knife not tactics nor technology nor
superpowers nor brutality time travel
but even without a machine we all travel
through time slowly and ever forward so
with my flesh protected from age by
apocalypse's Arcane technology but my
mind restlessly aware I did that one
thing that came would find abort I took
the long way around and all the while I
sharpened my mind and steeled my focus I
had many coming victories to contemplate
but I was drawn particularly to the
failures the ones I had been trained to
prevent I contemplated ravana the
mystery of her name echoing on my Elder
self's lips and of meeting my own ravana
in the distant past I shed my Boyhood to
make myself her murderers undoing and
finally in the shadow of 26
964 years of preparation meditation and
patience I arrived and so he basically
shows up here in what's essentially the
modern era right the modern day and when
I say the modern day I mean like The
Avengers in the 1960s really is is
really what I'm referring to here but
when he arrives here this sarcophagus of
course is discovered and of course he
ends up breaking out and so on and so
forth but as he's here of course he
overhears a news blip on the radio from
Jay Jonah Jameson where basically
there's some kind of uh UFO right a
hovercraft out there that's just like
wreaking havoc and the Avengers are
fighting it and so on and so forth and
where they don't quite know what to make
of it and in fact Jameson asked a
question like is it Invaders from outer
space Kang is like no that's my future
self who's arrived here with the
intention of attacking the Avengers team
now what's really really interesting
about this and this is what's really
really cool is that you have younger
Kang who shows up to this vessel now in
his mind he doesn't spend a whole lot of
time with the Avengers they're really
more of an afterthought here and that's
one of the things that's so cool about
this story is whenever we traditionally
read comic books The Avengers or
somebody like that they're always in
some capacity the main focus right like
here's a Spider-Man story where Peter
Parker's doing his thing and something
happens and some villain shows up you
know whatever he's really really strong
Peter can't do it on his own so here
come the Avengers and now it's a team up
book you don't really see instances
where it's just like and they're The
Avengers over there doing something
let's go back to what it is that we're
doing here like you never really see
that all the time right and it's really
I really enjoy it's one of the things
that I loved about books like this is
it's basically saying like younger King
who's like I gotta fight my older self
and it's cool to see The Avengers
because I remember seeing them when I
was a little kid way you know in the
far-flung future you know when he's from
the 31st Century but he's like I
remember seeing them as a little kid
studying about them and like the museum
and the libraries and different things
like that so it's kind of wild to
actually see them here and they kind of
look like I always imagine them in my
memory that they were much bigger than
they are you know they're just people
here who do some stuff so there is a bit
of nostalgia here but it's one of those
things where he doesn't quite have time
to sit back and Marvel at The Avengers
fighting against you know the forces of
Kane to conquer instead can't like
younger Kang ends up going into the
vessel now it's one of these things and
this is a really really important aspect
of this he says so as The Avengers
fought Kang with shield and Hammer I
approached not as Alexander but as
Odysseus I made Kings time ship know me
as a friend for none could access its
Arsenal but K perhaps as I recall it now
that moment was the first time I was
truly him and the reason why he says
that and the reason why this is so
significant again is because over the
course of this story younger Kang has
been doing everything he can to prevent
himself from becoming older King the
Conqueror from like becoming that
villain it's a cool thing here because
in the midst of this battle of course
the Avengers kind of get the upper hand
Kang ship is is on the verge of getting
ready to take off and younger Kang ends
up confronting Alder King so like the
videos that we've done in the past we'll
refer to younger King as Nathaniel and
older Kang is just King right we'll just
call him that so the thing about this is
that Kang does not recognize Nathaniel
Richards and the reason why he doesn't
recognize him is because Kang has not
met him yet now I know it sounds
confusing as hell
this is why I say King stories man you
have to really approach these carefully
like especially if you're if I'm making
a video about this I have to approach it
very very carefully because I could just
blow through it the way that we normally
do with stories it would confuse the
piss out of here so here is a super
simple explanation to why it is that
Kang does not know Nathaniel so in a
previous video we talked about how Kang
despite only being probably in his 30s
or so has traveled back and forth
Through Time a ton of times and as a
result of that you could argue he's
cumulatively lived a thousand lifetimes
and so it's very very easy to just
forget things now what's important about
this is that Kane the Conqueror at this
point in his history has not traveled
back to find his younger self and
basically train his younger self and
teach him everything he needs to know to
prevent him from losing this is the
point in the story when Kane the
Conqueror is facing off against the
Avengers and losing so he hasn't come to
this realization what if I just go back
and grab my younger self and basically
correct all my mistakes in that younger
self so when my younger self becomes me
they won't have all the flaws that I
have now they'll be a better version of
me so they never make the same mistakes
and they ultimately come out on top
right that's why Kang does not remember
Nathaniel because he hasn't met him yet
because he hasn't come up with that idea
to grab Nathaniel and teach him
everything he needs to know to ensure
that Kang does not lose in these various
fights that he engages in now the thing
about this is remember Nathaniel doesn't
want to become Kang so even though he
accesses the ship by pretending to be
king and so on and so forth he still
stands against him right and one of the
things to keep in mind is he still
Harbors a lot of love for ravana
rensslayer and he's still very very mad
about the fact that she died in ancient
Egypt because of the actions of Kang
when he was pretending or operating
under the moniker of Rama Tut and so
what he says is that his intention is to
eradicate King right to kill King Here
and Now on this ship and by doing so it
would remove him from the time stream in
his entirety at that point he would go
back into the past in ancient Egypt and
he would save the life of ravana
rensslayer because if he were to go back
in the past and save the life of ravana
king would always end up back there
because it's just his history he would
always become Rama tud he would always
exist in ancient Egypt in that situation
with how ravana died would always repeat
itself but if he can kill Kang and by
doing so purge him from the time stream
in its entirety then ultimately he can
go back to ancient Egypt he can save the
life of ravana live a live a life with
her and never have to worry about Kang
showing up there to wreak havoc in any
capacity because he's dead right like
there's there's no King to travel back
and forth in time anymore and so the
response of Kang is that's insane like
do you have any idea what you would do
if you did that right like I'm so
ingrained in the time stream you would
quite literally break time itself but if
I didn't exist and you killed me it
would destroy time there has to always
be a king there needs to always be a
cane to conquer traveling back and forth
Through Time engaging in these different
things because this is how it's supposed
to work it's kind of ambiguous and it's
very meta textual in terms of How It's
explained but really it points to the
greater argument here that in Marvel
Comics there does always have to be a
king but Kang always comes into
existence it always ends up that way I
mean I guess maybe there's a universe
out there where there is no King the
Conqueror but that Universe has never
been seen right King always exists in
every Universe across the Multiverse
seemingly every single time now what's
crazy is that in the midst of this
argument between the two suddenly
they're met by the arrival of Victor Von
Doom of Dr Doom's son now here's a cool
thing right Dr Doom would normally never
intervene here and he certainly probably
wouldn't take the risk of showing up and
confronting Kane to conquer in his own
ship where he's at his most powerful but
the opportunity is too good of a chance
to pass up that Dr Doom watching the
entire conflict between Kang and the
Avengers and even being able to see
what's going on here using sorcery and
mysticism and whatnot came to the
realization there's two kings here there
is King from the future and King King
from the past right his younger self if
he can eradicate both then ultimately it
would save Doom a lot of Hassle and
grief and Kang likes standing in his way
regarding domination because one of the
things to know is that it's kind of an
unofficial competition between doom and
King in the sense that like Doctor Doom
wants to conquer the world but so does
Kane conquer and so they usually end up
bumping heads in terms of their various
schemes there is a kind of respect among
them it's grudging in the sense where
Doom like respects what it is a king's
capable of and Kang respects Doom then
there's also the the link that Marvel
has kind of created or teased but never
actually solidified that came to
conqueror may very well be descended
from Doctor Doom we never get a
definitive answer on that we don't know
if that's actually the case but
regardless of the situation Doom sees
this as a chance to take out two birds
with one stone and so what you have is a
massive battle that basically takes
place between the three of them to a
degree now when I say to a degree it's
because it's really more Kane the
Conqueror trying to take out Doctor Doom
and then it's Nathaniel trying to reason
with king and the reason why he says
that is because he says look ultimately
the immediate thread here is Doctor Doom
but you in you know in the in your
future will come back and find me and
when you find me you're going to take me
to the through the time stream and
you're going to try to correct all the
flaws In Yourself by correcting those
flaws and me teaching me those lessons
never love different things along those
lines right love is a weakness the the
fact that you fell in love with ravana
rensslayer is what led to you becoming
as weak and incapable as you are if I
don't have any of those weaknesses I
will become ruthless in a way that you
never work I will become every ounce
conqueror but at the end of the day I
can just teach you those things myself I
come from what is in effect your future
right like I know your history I know
what happens to you like I know these
conflicts but I know what happens to you
running all the way up until like the
31st Century so I know how your battles
with the Avengers will unfold I know all
that stuff so just let me teach you
those things right let me teach you how
you lost so that you can win and so as a
result of that the bargain is struck the
deal is made Kang says okay they
basically end up ejecting uh Dr Doom
from the ship using using you know time
mechanics and then once Dr Doom's out of
the picture the the response of King is
okay let's do this and the response of
Nathaniel is no right Doom was 100 right
Kang is not to be trusted your time is
done and he fires on him he literally
executes his older self right just kills
him right there and then shoots him to
death and it's just this amazing moment
where where King says king is dead Long
Live King and the argument that he makes
here what he's basically saying is you
are going to become me there's no way
you're not there's no way you can't
right like you are doing exactly what I
would have done right like you like
whether you know it or not you are
walking headlong into this role you're
walking headlong into becoming Kang and
so that's what's so funny here because
at this point once king is dead
Nathaniel says okay now I can execute my
plan I can Dawn the moniker of ramatant
and I can go back to ancient Egypt and I
can save the life of ravana rensslayer I
won't use the diode raid that forces her
to bend to my will instead like I will I
will conquer Egypt right I will see my
younger self so in effect it's exactly
everything that we saw happening in the
last video that we covered it's all
unfolding the difference here is that
the motivation of Rama Tut is different
but everything else is the exact same
what his younger self is there so on and
so forth and he tells ravana like okay
so like like basically I'm gonna take
you to a place where I'm going to keep
you safe right I'm going to take you to
this Citadel it's going to keep you safe
everything's gonna be fine but he still
operates its Rama Time by all Sanders
and measurement he's still a villain
because it's the role he has to play in
order to save the life of ravana you see
how he's falling down this path of
becoming King right like you see how
like he's just continually becoming this
guy and that's when the Fantastic Four
show up and they see him as Rama tut the
fight unfolds and so he says I did
exactly what Kane the Conqueror would
have done right what Romans HUD did
initially I fled so regardless of the
fact that he's trying to do things
differently in the end he's doing them
the exact same way the timeline unfolds
the exact same way and that's really the
bigger Focus here is that time is not
something you can just control and
manipulate however you want to it has a
finite Form and Function it starts at a
and it ends at Z and that there are
things that happen in between where you
can kind of fudge them a little bit but
at the end of the day there are fixed
points in the universe's history that
cannot be changed they cannot be
modified they cannot be adjusted there
are Universal constants that have to
exist in the universe King the Conqueror
is a universal constant Rama Tut's
existence is a universal point in the
time strength that cannot be adjusted it
always happens how it is that he wants
it to happen is irrelevant but it always
happens right he basically like no
matter what would take place here no
matter what his thought process would be
no matter what would happen it would be
him traveling back as Rama Tut and he
would give people science but he would
still be Rama Tut there's no way to
escape that so what ends up happening is
once he is once he flees and gets away
as best he can he ends up in the
far-flung future and 4000 A.D and the
first person he's greeted by is ravano
rensslayer which begs the question how
did ravana rinselayer survive from the
days of ancient Egypt to now so in Earth
and in the 40th Century as the way that
you're seeing this play out words quote
unquote Rama taught who ends up in the
40th Century that's technically accurate
that's the way it played out in comics
originally when it came to Kane the
Conqueror the difference here is that
this version of ramatud is not the same
as the way it was originally done in
Marvel Comics since the reason why we're
getting this change in origin that Rama
Todd was the tried and true Kang
operating under the guise of ramatut who
was ultimately defeated by The Fantastic
Four fled back to his era ended up in
the 40th century and so in in the way
the comics were originally told it was
basically a different version of
ramadath than the one that we see here
right Nathaniel his motivation for why
he did what he did when he was ramatud
was totally different him operating as
ramatut here now in the 40th century is
different but again it's Marvel
basically solidifying that no matter
what Nathaniel does he will always
become king and he'll always follow the
path of the person that ends up becoming
Kank that is unavoidable and there's no
way to escape it the way we know this is
that when he shows up here what he finds
himself in is basically a war-torn
territory now one of the big differences
here is that in the Original Stories the
way it was told by ramitut right so
Avengers 269 Captain America annual
number 11 ravana rensslayer didn't exist
or at least she wasn't there when he
appeared in the 40th Century not the way
that she is here so again it's Marvel
just kind of Shifting things around and
really retelling the origin of ravana
which really kind of begs the question
is King volume 1 a retelling of of
King's origin or a reworking of ravana
right like if you had to pick one as the
main focus of the story which one would
it be I mean technically it's both but
which one does it lean more towards I
guess is the more accurate question to
ask but when he shows up here of course
immediately being met by ravana the the
whole idea behind life in this future is
that it's very harsh right it is a very
harsh and just a battle hardened life
and more often than not in Marvel Comics
that's how the future is depicted to us
is given to us in different ways but the
future's shown as a very hard and Bleak
and dark place right Days of Future Past
the era of Apocalypse in the far-flung
future right when apocalypse rules the
world this era of Kang like all these
different things right it's a very harsh
and difficult place to be in right new
Canaanites versus the chosen or the
clanicaba or whatever it is is always
that kind of thing right so it's really
interesting to see that Marvel sort of
keeps this maintained but against these
forces what you have here is ravana
rinselayer leading by all standards of
measurement A Primitive race for the
most part that there are weapons and
arms and Armament here but because of
because of the fact that society as it
existed at the time had effectively
collapsed these arms and Armament are
Beyond ravana rensslayer in her people's
ability to understand they can use them
to a degree but they can't use them to
their fullest potential and so what's
really cool is that as the two of them
fight together much like what we saw in
their initial appearances in ancient
Egypt they fall in love just like they
did before that their love is born and
bred in Conflict just like it was before
and the two of them working as a group
Face Off against the the these Barbarian
hordes just like they did before the big
difference here though is that what you
have is this point where once these
forces are defeated again the world's
not saved so to speak it's just this
kind of immediate battle that what you
have is that with these forces
essentially defeated that Nathaniel
tells ravana like you're like like
you're amazing and and and I love you
the thing about this though is that he
always speaks of a time in which they'd
known each other in the past she doesn't
know him she's as far as she's concerned
she's never met him so what he's trying
to do is he's trying to kind of continue
on the life they could have had with a
person who knows nothing of that life
right as far as she's concerned and the
way that she feels he feels like he's
losing her and he's pushing you know
forcing himself on her and she's
rebuking him in that way right I mean
she she's growing to care about him but
he's basically moving too hard too fast
and as a result of that he basically
tells her like we can leave this place
right like like together we can leave we
can leave this life behind and we can go
to a place where we can live a glorious
life and when he gives her that
Revelation she immediately turns against
it now there's a few different reasons
as to why she turns against it and turns
against him the first is because this is
the only life she knows it's the only
life that she's even willing to accept
she can't imagine a life where there is
no such thing as conflict or war or
anything along those lines but the
bigger idea behind this is that because
of the life that she's lived she's grown
to become ridiculously independent and
doesn't see herself as somebody that can
be claimed by any person and the idea of
Nathaniel showing up here using what is
in effect an archaic standard of love
and connection and saying that like
you're my girl we knew each other in the
past right you don't know me now but you
can know me again I'm gonna take you
away from this place it almost puts her
in a feeling of being subservient which
is something that she immediately
regrets and so in doing so that's what
she says like you would you would tell
me that you knew me in the past right
she says all this power that you have
you used to claim me as you claim this
woman that you loved except that she is
not me and I am not yours I belong to
myself and the moment that we've made
this moment we've had here will be our
last you will never see me again and she
leaves and so in essence and that's
what's kind of cool here is that the way
ravana rimslayer is depicted here these
different instances where she appears in
the life of Nathaniel and then he loses
her that's designed to mirror the
appearances of ravana rensslayer in the
life of Kane the Conqueror the
difference is that in those lies it was
usually her being betrayed and her being
killed in front of Kang or something
along those lines but regardless no
matter how the circumstance played out
it was each one of them losing the woman
they loved and in losing the woman they
loved ultimately where Kang saw that as
a weakness Nathaniel sees it as how it
is that he becomes king and so that's
why he says he kind of reiterates the
words that were told to him by King
never love and he says as if it were a
choice and then he just kind of steps
into everything right he accepts his
role and he says fun if the choice was
to be mine between a heart pierced by
her gaze and one hardened against her
then I would choose Conquest like in
effect he's tired of losing her right
he's tired of experiencing all this loss
and all this pain over and over and over
again and so what he says is my Army was
unwashed untrained Savage and cruel but
one fact is true throughout time slaves
will become slavers when given a chance
to hold the Whip and he says ravana was
incorrect my mind was my greatest tool
for the weapons of war left behind by
those magic fools in her stories were
made of the very technology I had
trained to repair in those long and
listless Childhood Days complexity had
worn on me he says I wish for something
simple and so I offered all the simplest
Choice join me or die many chose death
and so what this means is that he goes
forward literally as a conqueror that he
starts to build this suit up for himself
that basically looks like the suit of
Kane the Conqueror that much like Kane
the Conqueror he starts to conquer the
world and then once he gets bored
conquering Earth he sets his sights out
on the entirety of the Galaxy itself
right and then the universe and over and
over and over again taking his forces
with him he conquers everyone and it's
so cool because he says my 100 Year
Conquest had begun he says what it once
seemed so distant so esoteric so
impossibly vast was now Within Reach I
needed only weight and watched the 40th
Century fall before me but I was not a
man of patience and with my time ship
reforged all of reality awaited my rule
should I have sat surrounded by the
ghosts of lost loves pondering how I
might learn from them or indulge my
glory across the fabric of space-time to
Nathanael it may have been a quandary to
Kang it was no choice at all and so he
says to ground the kings of the past to
dust Arthur most of all his cries were
not those of a hero but of a child who
thought Destiny would not be swayed
against him the cosmosian monarchs
believe themselves safe in their Quantum
Dimension I showed them the error of
their ways then blessed their endless
cities by reforging them as factories
for my time spanning war machine over
and over and over again is the exact
same way he meets immortus he defeats
immortus he meets the Scrolls he defeat
the Scrolls the Batoon the shiar
literally the entire universe is
conquered by Kank that Nathaniel and
that's what's so crazy here that were
Kang like the the king that initially
appeared saw love as weakness Nathaniel
sees it as strength not in the sense
that it's his love for ravana rensslayer
that makes him the person that he wants
to become But ultimately it was the
losing of Love of ravana rensslayer that
drove him to become the person that he
is and so ultimately he says once all of
this was said and done at the end of the
day I still never found anything I still
couldn't feel anything I had conquered
the entirety of the universe and yet
something was still missing from my life
some thing that I felt like I needed
that I wanted I simply just couldn't
find anymore and so what he does is he
travels back to Earth after hearing that
there is a single Kingdom out there that
remains unconquered by his forces and so
ultimately when he arrives here that he
ends up finding that this is the last
free Kingdom that's ruled by ravana
rensslayer now this it's been quite some
time since the ravana rim Slayer he
immediately met and in fact he even
comments on that he was like okay it was
her it was ravana rinselayer yet again
right a different face but those same
eyes and so what this seems to hit at is
that ravana rinselayer is in a lot of
ways a concept an ideology I mean she is
a person but the big question that has
to be asked here which we'll actually
find out really in the next video
is how it is that ravana rensslayer
keeps reappearing as different people in
the time stream right how is it that in
the days of ancient Egypt she had
appeared albeit not necessarily uh as
the ravana rinselayer that we're
familiar with she shows up in the motto
or really about 100 years ago in the
40th century and then she shows up again
here and each time she seemingly looks
different how does that happen but the
reality here is that when he does appear
to ravana rensslayer the first thing he
wants to do is win her heart right the
first thing he wants is to have his girl
back but the reality here is she sees
him as a conqueror she doesn't see him
as a person she could love she sees him
as a person that she absolutely hates
and so what he really realizes is that
the only way to get ravana rensslayer
the only way to get her love is to show
her who he really is because the reality
here and this is one of the best things
about this story came the Conqueror as
you see him here he's not genuinely that
guy but Nathaniel is not genuinely some
warlord that wants to conquer all of
existence for no other reason the fact
that it feeds his ego what he's what he
wants is to find some measure of meaning
out there what he's doing here by
conquering everything is filling the
hole in his heart that was left by not
having ravana Rim Slayer but who he is
at his core is a genuinely great person
right it's a genuinely good guy and
that's when he realizes I have to
actually show her who I am in order for
her to truly love me and that's what he
starts doing right that's literally what
he starts doing is he starts basically
operating as effectively a hero right
that he calls off the attack on her
kingdom and then he frees her kingdom
and says like you do your thing right
like your kingdom is totally hit like we
are hands off not only that he basically
allies himself as Heroes right the ones
that were essentially time to but he had
he acts as Heroes all the while his
General right boltag is plotting against
him and so there comes a point where in
reality the idea of ravana rinselayer as
she appears here being killed does
happen at the hands of baltag right it
does happen as him who ultimately does
shoot her and so basically taking him
out as the traitor saves the life or
seems to save the life of ravana
rensslayer and so ultimately he wins her
heart right he finally gets ravana Rin
slayer's love and in that moment baltag
shoots her right in the moment when he
basically Reveals His role as a traitor
before Kane can act ravana Rin Slayer is
killed and so that's it's one of the
coolest moments here right he says I
prepare to end battle tag as Kang never
had but for a moment I stay my hand for
I have fallen in love and it is not
conquered me it is my Mercy she has
grown to love I win and time lasts
because once she's dead and gone it's
the thing where she says maybe it was
just never meant to be maybe we were
just never meant to be together and Kang
basically almost breaks on this personal
level right the one chance he had to
finally have ravana rensslayer the
closest he ever got to having the woman
of his dreams and is yanked away it's
pulled away because in reality King and
King can never have ravana rinselay
right it's the the torment of him as a
person he will never get ravana he will
never be in love with Pravana he will
never have the life he wants with ravana
that's never going to happen and so what
he does and this basically goes into how
it is that Ren Slayer appears across the
time stream and he says and so it was
then that I devised a new Escape my love
one the old man could never have
accomplished one that I know I already
will he spent the next 50 years mourning
you when you initially died he says in
his time right King's time he spent the
next 50 years mourning you trying to
bring you his ravana back but I have
seen your face in the distant past and I
have seen your face only a hundred years
ago and I see you here now and where he
was told never love he says I have
already seen the ripples in the waters
of time but I remained so ignorant as to
the impact that caused them but I know
now what else could it be I am the
impact and I shall shatter time for you
awake ravana awake 1 000 times and be
saved by my final conquest and so the
goal of Kane the Conqueror is to quite
literally shoot ravana rensslayer's
Essence into the time stream and
basically use that as a way to find a
reality where he can have ravana
rinselayer back so it's really cool
right again it's as much a retelling as
keeping components of the original
origin of King and Tech I mean I would
surmise all this is being done because
of Kang in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but it's really cool uh in this video
and this what's really cool here about
this conclusion is that this is what
really solidifies King and and I would
say removes him from being just kind of
like this ambiguous conqueror that
exists out there in the Multiverse
somewhere that like does things from
time to time and actually brings these
are more Down to Earth because in
reality that's kind of what Kang needed
that over the years and Marvel Comics
King has just kind of been this guy who
exists in the future sometimes he shows
up he fights The Avengers every once in
a while you get like what is it the
original Avengers forever and the
timekeepers and immortus and all that
kind of stuff in the destiny Force but
you never really got to see a story that
focused so heavily on why Kang is the
way he is and what this one does is it
really changes that so the idea here is
that following what was basically the
death of ravana Ren's Slayer right the
one woman he's ever loved more than any
other that Kang's desire to conquer was
less about just like creating some
massive Empire for himself right in the
last video we talked about how he did
that but it left him feeling empty it
didn't fill that hole that he thought it
would fill because the reality is that
hole was reserved for rivona rensslayer
but without her in the picture he just
wasn't really able to do the kind of
things he wanted to do and that's what
was so cool is because he didn't feel
complete when it comes to this idea of
love and this is one of the things that
I want to specify here right when it
comes to the idea of love I think it's
very easy to take a cynical approach
right love is the only socially
acceptable version of masochism right
like we go out into the world and we
intentionally harm ourselves over and
over and over again in the hopes that it
won't actually hurt this time and we'll
find the person we love more than any
other it's very easy to become cynical
in that way when it comes to the notion
of love and for fair reason right I mean
there are people who've been hurt so
consistently that they just by default
associate love with pain because that's
the only thing love has ever caused them
is pain but the reality here is that
depending on who you talk to some people
will say it's worth it and what Kang is
doing here this is one of the things to
know the establishment of chronopolis
was not built at some place for Kane to
basically rule his Empire from some
distant point in the future across the
entirety of the Multiverse instead it
was to basically find his love and so
when he establishes chronopolis one of
the things to know and the easiest way
to understand this is that it's like
this Empire right this Citadel that he
has that has strings across the
Multiverse he is almost like like Thor
in the bifrost right that like you have
Asgard and you have the bifrost bridge
that allows Thor to access any of the
dimensions that are tied to the bifrost
chronopolis allows King to access any of
the universes that he's conquered and
even some of the ones that he hasn't
right it allows him to basically travel
back and forth throughout the entirety
of the time stream and the Multiverse
it's just kind of his base of operations
it was also the base of operations for
immortus as well but the thing about
this is is why it was built was because
of the fact that what he wanted to do
was create a place whereby he could
essentially scatter the entirety of
ravana Rin slayer's atoms across the
time stream now I know it sounds kind of
crazy in doing that but he literally
says I call this place chronopolis he
says this is where we will live ravana
and he says where you'll live I swear it
even if it takes a thousand attempts she
was not you but she had wisdom go my
ravana and be infinitely reborn in the
space between the Stars so the idea of a
kayak behind King here is to basically
scatter her entire existence across the
Multiverse and she'll be reborn in every
single universe that exists across the
Multiverse at that point is him just
trying to find things now what he says
here is so intriguing he says in those
moments of Mastery for I had become the
master of time I often thought that
epochs and eras were measurements for
lesser men that had not invented the
chronology that could contain Kank I
brought the chronopolis the greatest
monks of the Buddha and the most
enlightened Shia Warrior priest and
through their teachings and on rare
occasions over their corpses I came to
an understanding a master does not allow
his love to die those are the actions of
a boy a master compels that which he
controls to become that which he loves
using every bit of chronopolis's power I
unravel the very fabric of taunt I found
the threads of fate and made the city
its Loom and from it I wove a machine of
constant replication I injected ravana
Rin slayer's very Soul into time like a
die into the threads of an entire
tapestry where time had taken her from
me I forced time to do the opposite the
birth of an infinite number of ravanas
in infinite timelines giving myself
infinite chances to save her the plan
was genius it was Flawless until it
began and what we end up finding out
here and this is one of the interesting
things dick hang really is it's almost
as though Kang has this Mastery of time
but he's also a slave to it because
every single reality that he goes to no
matter what he does she always dies that
in one reality she dies from the plague
and another reality she actually rejects
him right and it takes him by surprise
but no matter what he does and no matter
how hard he tries he always loses ravana
rensslayer there's nothing he can do to
have her no matter what the circumstance
is there's no way to get her and after
all these countless attempts after all
these efforts what it's done is has
turned him cold and that's one of the
things to know here and that's one of
the thing to see is that what we don't
necessarily know the exact origin of the
original Kang at the beginning of the
story that went back and visited
Nathanael who became this version of
Kang that we're seeing now all we know
is that their Origins seem very very
closely intertwined that the causation
behind what made them who they are is
still the exact same thing that when he
finally finds a version of ravana
rinselayer that he's that he comes to
believe may love him the reality is she
rejects him and it's not due to anything
regarding his character or at least his
physical form and so far that she finds
it unattractive or anything like that
she rejects him because of his character
and what he'd done to her and what she
really States here is she says the great
machine knows time it sees all those who
manipulated plus I could smell you
across the time stream you hideous
Jackal and she says my life you made me
believe you were a good man and then you
stole my life and where King says no I
saved you ravana you saved me and I
loved you I love you so I saved you the
response here is she says my life was
not yours to save my life was my life
right I died presumably when I was
supposed to or by whatever manner or
whatever means but what you've done is
you've taken my life away from me right
you have taken away my ability to
actually live a life that was meant for
me instead every life I've ever lived
across the entirety of this Multiverse
has all been engineered by you every
single life has been designed like
intricately by you not in so far is
exactly how her life unfolded but
basically she was created for a purpose
and the purpose was to satisfy the
desire of King to have someone in his
life imagine if that were the case but
imagine if tomorrow somebody showed up
to you to visit you and said hey the
whole reason you exist is because I
created you and I created you for the
express purpose of being my lover
suddenly your life has no meaning your
life has no value because the life you
lived was never truly your own and
that's what she experiences here that's
what really torments her here and so
where Kang realizes she's kind of a
failure that Ultra really King says okay
fine another failure there's nothing I
can do here he goes to attack her and
basically destroy her and in the process
of this she destroys chronopolis right
she says you're the wound in the time
stream King like you fail to realize
even after all of this you're the
problem and that's one of the things
that the king says here right he says
that all that's left to do here is to
cauterize the wound and he says I do not
remember these moments well right
because just his whole manipulation with
time screws with his memory and he says
I think I did not want to remember the
screams and he says and of course time
was collapsing the end of my rescue
operation was much closer than I'd
imagined so the mind as it often does
while exposed to the time stream Place
tricks it erases efficiently redacts and
kindly revises but I can still remember
her smile and the terror that it
inspired and so literally as the final
Act of this ravana rinselayer before
she's destroyed she annihilates the
entirety of the chronopolis and so he
says the ashes of chronopolis are there
if you look for them no matter what your
temporal position a bit of dirt on your
mantle a penny from a distant year a
book that you swore to read the
chronopolis just as its very function
and operation literally exploded
throughout the time stream with its
atoms and bits and pieces just kind of
skewed everywhere and what he says is
that in its destruction Kang unlike you
and I who would just kind of be blown
back maybe a hundred feet or 50 feet or
500 feet or whatever it is King was
blown through the time stream and so he
literally fell through time and so it's
one of those things because as he was
falling he says I arrived 10 minutes
early and then ultimately he arrived to
see his younger self and he says I was
younger than I'd remembered Nathaniel
Richards eyes I remembered once as my
own I had felt so powerful so capable I
looked at Kang with disdain the sneer
was insufferable I swore to erase it
from the boy I gave him the chance I'd
been given by the monster sister who
made me but with the benefit of my
knowledge I would give him the trauma I
would do it right right I would correct
the mistakes of of essentially my father
right I would correct the mistakes of
the king that came to me that visited me
when I was younger and brought me
through the time stream what's so
beautiful about this story is it's the
relation between a father and a son now
it's not exactly a father and a son but
by all standards a measurement You could
argue that it is right king's parents
when he was a child were already dead he
was basically raised without any real
parents at all so when King from the
future came back to visit his younger
self took him under his wing into the
time stream he very much became a father
figure but what he was was a father
figure that was traumatized by his own
experiences his own abuses his own
personal torment and as a result of that
much like a lot of parents out there he
passed that on to his child and so it's
really an answer to the question what
happens when a child is raised by a
parent that never learns the real
lessons of their own experiences and
that they try to to impart on their
children the better parts of themselves
but in their failure to learn their
lessons they ultimately impart on them
the worst parts of themselves that at
the end of the day the story of Kang is
cyclical it's always a circumstance
where Kang always becomes king but
notice this it's not Kang showing up
here and saying I will teach you to
become a conqueror so that you may
enslave all of existence no he says I
remember the wood under my fingers the
betrayer tears that left unbiden into my
eyes did his mouth Taste of bile did I
lay bleeding did he shiver and sweat and
he says did he feel the Noose tightened
around his throat an inescapable moment
a broken heart hate Fury so hot it will
burn the stars and so ultimately that's
what happens right he says what had been
was again the lesson he needed the one
that in my Fury I felt forced to teach a
lesson and so ultimately it's exactly
the same thing doesn't matter what
happened no matter how things unfolded
Kang can never have ravana the rent
Slayer he will never have that woman in
his life he is always destined to lose
that which he loved the most and like
any rational human being out there in
the face of losing what they love the
most he felt anger and instead of
accepting the fact that that's just the
way things unfolded for him he basically
took that anger and that rage and passed
it on to his younger self and what he
thought was basically the right lesson
to teach never loved and so literally
this cycle of abuse just continues that
while the lessons may have been a little
bit different or how he taught his
younger self may have been a little bit
different at the end of the day the root
cause was the exact same and so that's
how Kang always becomes king that he
says one last chance to save ravana I
had been given one last chance and I
done only what time demanded I was no
master I was a boy it made me hate him
all the more that she knew me even from
the start as I danced with Addie she
knew she knew me for what I am but all I
wanted to be was more than Nathaniel
Richards and so in the end what he was
trying to do was basically make
Nathaniel the opposite of him he was
trying to make Nathanael a person that
wouldn't become him but the lesson that
Nathaniel learned just like the lesson
this version of Nathaniel learned when
he was visited by the king before him
was that that version of Kang was a bad
guy that he would seek to destroy him
all the while failing to realize he
would become him and that's what he says
right he says that like that younger
version of Nathaniel left in the night
stealing the only time armor that he
thought Kang owned and Kang even says
Run Nathaniel run and become you think
me conquered but it was not Kang who has
died this day for Nathaniel Richards is
not a boy nor a man nor hero nor a
villain he is only a beginning and he
says a king and a tyrant a villain and a
hero we will be all things experience
all things the beginning and ending of
time and hours by immortalities Boon you
will have the power of a God and when
you have lived an Immortals life still
here you will stand never love and he
says how could I when there is no one
left to love across all of time my
ravanas are gone my past affixed it's
Loop completed her grip upon my heart
releases and so the husk stops I have
found my desiccation and he says let
Armageddon be a funeral pyre for there
is but one escape from eternity's Trap
and I stand upon its precipice I need
not even junk I need merely to finally
rest Alexander wept because he could not
conquer himself but I am not Alexander
and literally that world that he's in
right when that meteor strikes he's
there at the very moment and simply
leaves right just leaves on his own
vessel and he says rest in fire
Nathaniel Richards rest knowing you have
bested all you thought to be great in
this world die knowing you stand a
stride Destiny give your face and voice
to he who created and who in turn turn
created you and above all things though
all on time and space make Inspire to
defeat you never ever love that's the
irony of this that's the irony and the
beauty of this whole story that when
Kang when when this version of Kang was
visited by the king before him that that
King said never love all it's going to
do is bring you pain and suffering and
sadness and the response of Nathanael
was that's because you didn't know love
all you knew was conquering loves the
greatest feeling in existence it's the
greatest thing of all and that at the
end of the day this that that younger
Nathaniel went on his quest to find a
way to defeat that King to destroy that
King to show that version of King that
love truly is powerful but when he
encounters it what that younger
Nathaniel failed to realize is the power
of love is so extreme that it can break
a person on the most fundamental level
and I'm not talking about those those
guys out there who really liked the girl
in their science class and they don't
like them back and so love is bad no no
I'm talking about the people who gave
their life to someone right I'm talking
about those men and women out there
right who lived a life with somebody
else who spent years together right
brushing their teeth next to each other
for 30 years and truly understand the
meaning of sacrifice right and that
significant other just changed their
mind one day and left or they were hit
by a car and they died whatever the case
is that that person became that person's
other half right like they had spent so
much time together that they were
intertwined in a way that can scarcely
be defined and when that person either
left or or was taken from them that that
person had become half their heart and
half their mind and half their soul and
how do you live without that right and
so to truly understand what it means to
love and then to have that taken away
and to not only have it taken away to
know you can never get it back it can
break a person on the most basic and
fundamental level and that's what
younger Nathaniel never accounted for
that's what he never considered is what
that what what it really meant to love
and then what it meant to never be able
to have that love that's what broke him
and so that's the the interesting lesson
here is at the end of the day came to
conqueror despite all of his wanted
power and despite all the things he says
and all the things he does in the grand
campaigns and all that kind of stuff
Kang is nothing more than a guy who
exists out there in time and has
experienced a broken heart an infinite
number of times
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with basically came to
conqueror now this is a story called
Timeless this is a one shot and this is
amazing because Kane the Conqueror is
gonna fight Doctor Doom and it's one of
the coolest things ever alright so check
this out so this story is written from
the perspective of a guy named Anatoly
Petrov and this guy is basically in the
present day because we're gonna actually
have some multiversal hijinks not really
traditional time travel hijinks we will
to a degree but what this guy's doing is
literally chronicling the stories of
different villains who have existed
across the world and what he ends up
saying here or the way he kind of lines
it out is that going pound for pound
looking at accomplishment versus
accomplishment that the greatest threat
the Earth has ever faced when it came to
various villains was actually Doctor
Doom that it was Dr Doom who was the
greatest threat no matter where you go
now this actually lines up really really
well with the story that we're covering
over on Thursdays which should come out
tomorrow which is Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four where even he establishes
that Dr Doom and every universe is the
greatest threat that universe is ever
going to face because his desire for
power is Limitless and he will capture
incredibly high levels of power right
his thirst is just unquenchable and so
ultimately Kang ends up visiting Dr
Petrov now some of this is just sort of
Kang being petty but he wants to prove
that he's actually better than Dr Doom
which is pretty straightforward but it's
one of those things it's one of those uh
interesting kind of situations because
Petrov asked him like are you here to
kill me and the response of Kang is no
right I'm here to show you or to do what
nobody else can do I'm here to change
your mind right I'm here to get you to
see me differently than the way that
you've seen me based on my different
hijinks and so on now that's an
important distinction to understand and
the reason why is because when it comes
to someone like Doctor Doom he's in
latviria right so he's literally right
over there you can just go see him over
there if you were foolish enough to do
so with Kane the Conqueror he exists in
the future of the 31st Century which
unless you're the Fantastic Four or
you're some person or group of people
out there with the ability to time
travel you don't really know King all
you know is Kang when he appears and
does some things now an argument could
be made if you wanted to be seen it's
more than what he was then he should
have just not been a dick every time he
showed up but still like that's that's
kind of the argument that's being
created here right and so this guy being
able to actually travel along with King
the Conqueror in his various conquests
and whatnot basically gives him a much
better understanding of who Kang is
about and so what this does is it
actually has him has Kang bringing
Petrov back to the early days of
humanity where he ends up fighting this
just gigantic woolly mammoth now the
funny thing about this and this is one
of the cool things when it comes to Kang
he is arguably one of the more powerful
members in Marvel Comics in terms of
what he can just do on his own which is
to say his fighting style or his powers
he's not really much of a challenge to
anybody what makes Kings so dangerous is
his ability to manipulate time he can
just go back in time and prevent you
from being born and so in the face of
the fact that a guy can prevent your
existence from happening again he kind
of Falls in that threshold of being one
of the more powerful characters more or
less because of what his technology
allows him to do and less so what he's
physically capable of doing but even
then when it comes to Kang despite all
that wanted ability what he prefers to
do is challenge himself on the personal
level and that's why in facing off
against this woolly mammoth he literally
just casts aside all this technology all
of his arms all of his Armament and then
decides to fight this thing with nothing
but a knife now this is designed to show
Dr Petrov what Kang's capable of in
one-on-one conflict which admittedly is
actually something Doctor Doom can't do
a lot of you guys don't know that Dr
Doom is not an accomplished fighter Dr
Doom is a guy who uses magic and
mysticism but when it comes to just
full-on one-to-one man-to-man bare
knuckle fighting Dr Doom doesn't really
have it right like it's just not
necessarily there every time he faced
off against the Incredible Hulk or
overpowered The Incredible Hulk or
something like that it was one of those
things where it was largely relegated to
him using some sort of magic or
mysticism in order to subscribe to this
YouTube channel which is what you should
be doing right now make sure you guys
hit the Subscribe button but in all
seriousness in order to achieve his goal
and so once this battle is done right
once this conflict is over and of course
you have Kang who's basically up on top
and he's the guy who's kind of you know
the the winner so to speak that what he
ends up doing is taking Dr Petrov back
to his vessel and then suddenly they end
up getting a chronal anomaly detection
basically it's like an earthquake right
something in the timeline is being
disrupted now this is one of the things
that Kang is always aware of right if
scientists always have these kind of
seismographs around the world in order
to determine when an earthquake is
happening then King has those all across
the time stream to know when someone's
traveling back and forth through time
now sometimes he'll do nothing it just
doesn't matter other times he'll
teleport there and he'll just watch and
he'll see how things unfold and then
there's times when he'll actually step
in and intervene this is one of those
times when he steps in and intervenes
now the cool thing about this is that
the way the king describes it is that
it's basically a Time Quake right that
something is exerting extreme chronal
gravity Upon Our timeline so here's
something that I want you guys to be
aware of right anytime you've ever
watched a a science film and there's
something like the Moon that crashes
into Earth during that garbage ass movie
moonfall or when you had like uh
Melancholia which is actually a
phenomenal movie and you basically have
some giant Celestial body that crashes
into Earth it doesn't work that way what
you actually have is something called
the Roche limit so quite literally if a
planet twice the size of Earth got close
enough the gravity of that planet would
actually start tearing chunks of the
earth apart until eventually the two
crashed into each other but it would be
that Celestial body crashing into what
remains of like a third of the Earth or
something along those lines that's
basically what's happening here that
this alternate reality is moving closer
and closer to the main Marvel Universe
and as it does it's quite literally
enacting the Roche limit which is
pulling the timeline apart that was
starting as kind of things on the
fringes of the universe itself just way
way out there where no one's going to
notice like an army that's creeping up
from 200 miles away but eventually it'll
get close enough to where everybody will
notice and then when it reaches that
point it will simply be too late and so
what ends up happening is Kang brings Dr
Petrov with him and they teleport to
this universe right they teleport to
this reality now one of the cool things
that goes on here is this story does
take place before a lot of the things
that we've read so far Avengers versus
X-Men versus eternals and so on and so
forth but one of the other things that
it does is it continues to tease the
upcoming Thanos story now for those of
you guys who aren't familiar with that
the upcoming Thanos story is a story
where Thanos gets the Infinity Stones
attaches them to the Hammer of mjolnir
that belongs to Thor which Thanos is
wielding he's also got the arm of the
Destroyer armor and he's leading an army
of the Dead God only knows what in the
hell happened to get to that point but
we will find out and I am excited so
here's the thing the way the king
describes this alternate reality is a
pirate timeline and the reality here is
that it's not supposed to be here so
what he ends up doing is actually giving
Dr Petrov this bit of an explanation
about the nature of immortus so for
those of you guys who are familiar with
Marvel Comics bear with me here because
I'm sure we're gonna have people who
don't know anything about Kang or
immortus or whatever so I'm going to
explain that to them here so for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with this
and to explain this in ridiculously
simplified terms immortus is the end
result of Kang and it follows a linear
progression right so in the 31st Century
Nathaniel Richard supposedly the
descendant of Doctor Doom ends up
discovering he can travel through time
the first thing he does is he goes back
to his younger self and he tells him
these are the decisions you need to make
so that you become me basically Kane the
Conqueror his younger self chooses to
Rebel he becomes iron lad the next thing
came the Conqueror does is he travels to
the distant past on Earth in Egypt and
he tries to conquer the world in Ancient
Egypt he calls himself Rama Tut he's
defeated by The Fantastic Four he's
supposed to go back to the 31st Century
but instead he discovers true Limba
which is a place that exists outside of
space and time in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe you refer to that place as the
quantum realm inside of limbo King
realizes that he's part of the bigger
Multiverse as a whole but also the
Multiverse has a very delicate balance
and so what he ends up doing is
basically striking a deal with the
timekeepers in that as immortus which is
what he calls himself now that he will
basically prune the timeline of any
alternate realities that are decaying or
dying or aren't supposed to be there
whatever the case happens to be using
whatever Rhyme or Reason makes sense to
Marvel Comics at the time it's literally
just that there's really nothing more to
it than that and so every time you pick
up a Marvel comic and you see King the
Conqueror like in this story this is
taking place between the time when
Nathaniel Richards discovered time try
travel in the 31st Century but before he
traveled to limbo and became immortus
that's basically when these things are
taking place hopefully that makes sense
let's get back into it so here's the
thing once this is kind of discussed the
idea behind it is that this timeline was
supposed to have been destroyed this
timeline was supposed to have just kind
of been set adrift and so what a mortise
would do is much like a dead flower or a
dead leaf on a tree he would prune it
meaning he would clip the branch and
when that happened it would basically
just drift off into the ether it's
supposed to effectively just disappear
right just kind of go into what is the
black hole of existence but something
happened in this universe where it
didn't instead of quote unquote falling
to the ground and dying it actually
started to pull itself back to the tree
or in this instance the main timeline
something is doing that and so that's
what Kang and Dr Petrov are going to
investigate now once they get there the
first thing they see and this is what's
so crazy about this the first thing they
end up seeing are all these dead
celestials right like all these dead
celestials everywhere and in fact the
sort of Damocles which was at one point
the base of Kane the Conqueror
presumably in this alternate reality
that's destroyed as well but whatever
this being is or whoever this person is
is able to destroy Cosmic entities
literally crush them and defeat them
which is no small feat that's colossal
right but this also indicates this
person can basically control the
fundamental forces of reality because it
looks like it was a hand-to-hand fight
where these guys were killed and so as
you end up having Kang and Dr Petrov who
enter into the Sword of Damocles and
make their way throughout this entire
Citadel they ultimately end up coming
across Doctor Doom now this is the crazy
thing here right like this is this is
the crazy thing it's not just Doctor
Doom right like he's like he's like I
have come Victor it's not just Doctor
Doom instead it's actually this Doctor
Doom who references not just Kang but a
Kang so what this seems to indicate is
more than one king the Conqueror has
traveled to this place and try to
destroy this guy because remember every
Universe in the Multiverse has its own
version of King the Conqueror so
different versions of Kang have
discovered that this universe is trying
to get back to the Multiverse and is
tearing apart timelines on its journey
and so they've come here trying to
defeat Doctor Doom and were probably
destroyed in in return and that's that
either that or he just destroyed his own
universes King and this is like the
second one he's met I don't know but
regardless of the situation what we end
up finding out here is that once this
version of Doctor Doom removes his
helmet that is not actually Victor Von
Doom this guy is Reed Richards that what
he had done is that in this alternate
universe when it had basically been
plucked from the timeline that null time
or basically the destruction of the
universe itself has started to creep in
right literally the universe started
falling apart at the seams the different
superheroes banded together and the
different superheroes were able to Stave
off their own destruction the problem
with this is that all it did was
basically slow things down there why was
no way to stop the destruction of this
universe as time went on because of the
fact that it's just kind of existing out
there and is going to be eaten or or
kind of consumed or destroyed not really
by like a physical being out there it's
simply just it's it's you existing out
in the desert for like you know 60 days
with no water right you're gonna die
long before you reach those 60 days
you'll die of dehydration and that's
literally what this what what happened
with this universe and so what ended up
going on here is this version of read
literally says the world was still sick
right still dying the entropic death of
our timeline was still occurring just an
inch at a time the world lost hope do
you know what happens to a society
without hope Kang total collapse and he
says I never lost hope not for the world
the trade-off is that I threw away any
hope for myself I would do anything to
save the world so I replaced my eyes
with the time and reality stones and
forced my will upon the timeline I I
killed celestials and drank their blood
to take their power for myself I
destroyed anyone who raised the hand
raised even their voice against me and
my mission my mission to save this
timeline so quite literally what Reid
Richards in this alternate reality did
is he killed Dr Doom he took his place
he took the time in the reality Stones
now he basically has the ability to
control all of time and space then he
kill the celestials and consumed their
power and so it's basically one of the
most powerful versions of Doctor Doom
that we've ever seen in Marvel Comics
the only two versions I would say that
are more powerful than this one is the
version of Doctor Doom that got The
full-on Infinity Gauntlet in an
alternate reality story and the version
of Doctor Doom that basically took the
power of the beyonder in the original
Secret Wars from 1984. a playlist that
you will find down in the description
which you are welcome to check out after
you're done with this video but the
thing about this is that as time
progresses right as this kind of
conversation goes on you end up
basically having Kane the Conqueror
launching his attacks against Dr Doom as
best he can but the funny thing about
this is that at the end of the day none
of it really seems to work and the
reason why is because with Dr Doom
controlling all of time and space and
with them being in an alternate reality
what Kang had done is he had brought all
of his arms and Armament with him he'd
brought all of his weapons with him and
he basically just kind of stored them
just slightly out of phase with the
existing Universe right so basically
like a second ahead so we can just kind
of reach and grab those and then come
back because remember with somebody like
hang who time travels for you and me it
might look like teleportation for for
Kane to conquer he teleported away at
five minutes to and then traveled ten
thousand years into the future and then
when he came back it was five minutes
and one second right that's how it would
look that's how it would be for king
that's what it's like when you can
basically control time so again it's a
pretty badass moment but the reality
here is realizing what Kang's doing and
because he controls time and reality
what Reid ends up doing is that actually
teleporting all of Kang's weapons to its
location and then basically destroying
all the weapons of Kang save for his own
sword and so again it's kind of
hearkening back to the beginning of the
story where Kang was facing off against
this giant woolly mammoth monster using
nothing but a knife but something that I
want you guys to notice here is that in
this fight against Doom where Kang is
just hopelessly outmatched to be quite
honest with you guys where he simply
just cannot be destroyed by Kang because
he's just way more powerful in terms of
all the energy that he has Anatoly
starts to see Kane the Conqueror in a
way that he just hadn't really seen
before and a lot of this is the writer
Jed McKay kind of really giving us this
change in perspective of King in the
sense that when you look at things like
the Fantastic Four where he shows up and
faces off against them or in Young
Avengers or even the Avengers Comics
themselves most appearances of Kane the
Conqueror are just him as some kind of a
demigod right just some kind of an
astronomical being who's just doing
crazy things and manipulating time and
trying to find some way to conquer the
world depending on what story you're
reading he feel feels like a villain of
the week but something that's going on
here and it's not even just Jed McKay
doing this it's Marvel in general
they're doing a lot more of these kind
of deep dives into the nature of King as
opposed to him just being a guy who
fights The Avengers manipulates time
assumes or symbols a giant you know
Council of himself that there's a lot
more to him than that and so where
people have looked at Kang and they've
seen him as almost a god-like entity
this man that manipulates and controls
time that for King himself Nathaniel
doesn't see himself that way he doesn't
see himself as some kind of a Godly
being who's Beyond reproach or anything
like that and in fact he's actually
relishing this conflict he's loving the
idea that in this fight against Dr Doom
that he could be killed that he could be
destroyed by this guy he just loves this
opportunity and he's just kind of living
for this moment but at the end of the
day one of the cool things he points out
and really just kind of gets into the
mind of read is he taunts him with the
idea that he was always going to be a
tyrant now this is an indication of how
well Kane the Conqueror knows Reed
Richards versus how well he knows Victor
Von Doom right Reed Richards being Mr
Fantastic the leader of the Fantastic
Four he's always calm he's always
composed but when we look at stories
like Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
Reed Richards forming the Council of
reads and then screwing things up when
we look at things like Civil War or we
look at the formation of the Illuminati
or even when you go into Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers The New Avengers run
and Reed has to come to the realization
that he can't save the Multiverse and
that seemingly this kind of falls on his
shoulders at least from his perspective
it's very easy for him to be emotionally
manipulated mentally not so much because
for the most part Reed's just too smart
for that but toying where there's
emotions getting him to think out of
being logical and more emotional that's
not difficult for King to do it's
difficult for most anybody else to do
but it's not difficult for Kane because
he knows The Life and Times of read the
thing about this is that as these guys
are talking and as they're progressing
and sort of doing their thing that what
happens is that in that moment when
literally Reed is about to kill Kang
that Anatoly kind of shows up out of
nowhere steals one of the weapons that
belongs to Reed himself the one that he
used to basically kill most everybody
there and then kills Reed with his own
Spear and so in that moment there's this
kind of conversation that happens
between the two of them because the
funny thing about this is that King
responds and says you would Aid the
Conqueror in single combat you
understand what this means do you not
and the response of Anatoly is I know I
know that you'll kill me for it and so
King responds and says then why why
would you do such a thing Court to death
you know I must dispense and the
response of Anatoly here is incredibly
insightful right he says if Doom
Richards killed you I would be dead
anyway and my timeline would be at risk
do you believe to be the Pinnacle of
humanity you must be greater than all
others you must put yourself before all
others but I believe that true human
greatness lies in putting others before
your yourself and so Cain kind of
overhears this and then just sort of
laughs at him right and then walks away
right of course he ends up bringing
Anatoly back but one of the things he
says is he says come on I believe our
time together is finished I will return
you to shortly after we left your office
and the response here where anatoly's
kind of like okay this is strange like I
thought my death was impending Kang
actually responds in a really
interesting way he says this is still my
victory I brought you with me as another
of my weapons Petrov Richards Doom the
one thing you can count on from them is
their arrogance this was all to plan but
you of course don't know that this is
the very reason I take on traveling
companions Petrov I like being
challenged you stood up to me knowing
that I would most likely kill you that
is the kind of Courage I have always
admired in humanity that is the element
that makes our species worthy that is
what Humanity possesses that has allowed
it to produce King and that's the cool
thing right that's the interesting thing
about Nathaniel Richards again when you
look at Kang from a different
perspective it's kind of hard to see him
as a guy where he's more than just some
dude who jumps back and forth through
time and causes problems but in this
moment here right now as he's talking to
Anatoly it's like I can respect those
who would look in the face of death and
laugh who would even challenge those who
are greater than them to me there is
nothing better among Humanity than a
person who looks to to basically become
better than who they are that's how I
got to where I am and that's what makes
Humanity great most people will never do
that 99 of people will fall Rank and
file and they'll live the life they live
because that's just what you're supposed
to do they'll never think outside the
box but for those who do they go on to
become great people and do great things
you're one of those people Petrov also
just be aware if you write your book and
you talk about how Doom's the greatest
villain of all time and not me I'm gonna
come back and kill you so just put my
name in there instead of Doom which is
really King in his most true form
so Doctor Doom fights Kane the Conqueror
and Mephisto in the story and it's
amazing okay so check this out so this
initially picks up with something called
the antleon collider which is basically
a black hole that's being created on the
dark side of the moon it's more of a
controlled black hole it's basically a
minor Singularity but the reason why
this is done is because the world or at
least the scientific community on Earth
in the Marvel Universe wants to start
shifting more towards like nuclear power
different things like that but with all
the different forms of energy that are
used the big question that people find
themselves asking is what do we do with
all this waste right this energy waste
that we end up creating is it one of
these things where we're going to just
kind of keep on doing what we're doing
which is driving to the side of a hill
dumping our trash in the ground and then
covering it up or are we going to come
up with something that's a little more
elegant and more of a fitting of our
technological advancement and so that's
the idea behind this black hole is to
literally create a place whereby trash
can be dumped essentially for Infinity
right because black holes will break
everything down on the atomic level and
it may end up filling up but I mean it's
it would take an astronomically long
amount of time in order for that to
happen the kicker to all this is that
while these interviews are being done
with members of the the antleon collider
Community they're also talking to Doctor
Doom and they asked him the question
like what's your stance on this of
course Doctor Doom being Dr Doom is like
it's gonna fail right this whole thing's
being done by Reed Richards as
intelligent as he is the biggest problem
Reed Richards has is that he's sloppy
and because he's sloppy this is going to
end up failing disastrously now the
crazy thing about this is that you do
have this guy named Steve who's one of
the guys conducting the interview right
one of these reporters and he literally
says many believe that you're just upset
because you were left out on the project
and it has to be a failure because you
weren't involved now here's the thing
right anybody who knows anything about
Doctor Doom in Marvel Comics knows that
there are some things you just don't say
right like pick your battles wisely this
is one of those because when the
interview ends Doctor Doom just kind of
leaves in a huff and then tell tells one
of his guys bring the reporter Steve to
me bring that guy to me right like I
want my hands on that guy he's been
mouthing off and we need to help Steve
understand his place in the bigger
picture and so one of the things that
kind of goes on here and it's cool is
that while that's taking place you end
up having Doctor Doom in his study and
while he's there he's suddenly met by
the arrival of King the Conqueror now
when it comes to King and Doctor Doom
this is one of those things where it's
kind of you stay away I stay away right
in the sense that because these two guys
are kind of distant relations to a
degree Kang doesn't really do a whole
lot in terms of intentionally going
after Victor Von Doom the reason for
that is that in Marvel Comics it's never
been fully established if Kane the
Conqueror is the descendant of Reed
Richards or the descendant of Victor Von
Doom but the risk here and even King
himself doesn't fully know if he were to
attack Doctor Doom anywhere to kill him
who could actually prevent his own
existence from happening and so he
doesn't really go directly against Dr
Doom and usually pick a fight although
the two have fought in the past and the
fight between Dr Doom and Kang are
usually amazing like they're some of the
coolest fights you're ever gonna see
mostly because it's Kane to conquer
brandishing all his technology and time
travel escapades and his Doctor Doom was
just like the best one-liners ever in
the history of comic books it's no no I
will say apocalypse has better
one-liners but Doctor Doom has great
one-liners he's got great lines but it's
just one of those things but it's also
because of the fact that Doctor Doom is
so astronomically intelligent and
because he's so capable and because his
lust for power in a lot of ways mirrors
that of Kang there is a kind of respect
that is grown between the two also
because of the fact they've helped each
other at different points in time and so
Kang being here is one of those things
where it's a little mysterious we don't
really know why he's here in the first
place the nature of the conversation is
really more just kind of banter back and
forth between the two and that's
basically it and then Kang ultimately
just sort of teleports away but what Dr
Doom ends up doing is zazi prepares for
bed that he actually ends up having this
vision of of a woman that we haven't
discovered yet and she and Dr Doom have
a family right like they have a whole
full-on family and so Dr Doom really
kind of going back to his quarters right
after this sort of hallucination which
really even takes him by surprise he
ends up opening the door only to find
that he's on the moon where the entire
antleon project has gone awry according
to his prediction it's manifested a
full-scale black hole and is sucking
everything in around it now here's the
thing to understand if a black hole
opened on the moon if we would die so
fast we wouldn't even be able to
understand what had happened right like
literally it would just probably be a
flash of light and like that's it that's
all we would see but the thing about
this is that once Dr Doom of course the
next morning he's basically told hey we
have Steve that uh he ends up going to
find where Steve is basically just kind
of strung up
and he's like make sure he's fed today
tomorrow we might not feed him but today
make sure he's fed and so as Dr Doom is
kind of meditating and focusing on this
Vision that he received suddenly the
nuclear arms of of latviria fire off
right they literally just start going
off like all these nuclear weapons of
latviria shoot off they head toward the
ant Leon uh Antion collider and
basically destroy the whole thing and
because they um because they originated
from latviria and because Dr Doom had
been like yeah man uh this the whole
this whole thing's gonna fail the
immediate suspect for all of this is Dr
Doom and these guys come swooping in
right just I mean it's it's shoot out of
the okay Corral right guns blazing the
first one to show up here is Union Jack
he doesn't really matter all that much
but he is cool right he's one of these
characters where he never really gets a
whole lot of appearances in Marvel
Comics but he is cool and it is
interesting to see him from time to time
but the funny thing about this is that
while this attack's going on suddenly
Victor Von Doom is shot by Agent Zero
now Agent Zero is a lot more capable
Maverick was one of the original
inductees into the Weapon X Program
alongside Wolverine so while he's not
necessarily on the same level as
Wolverine regarding like adamantium
bonding and all that kind of stuff he is
probably one of the single greatest
assassins and mercenaries in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe it's
crazy how good he is and he even goes as
far as to say interpol's reward right
the international police the reward just
shot up for Victor Von Doom like
literally everybody's got it out for
this guy everybody's coming for this guy
and so where Dr Doom is able to
initially get the upper hand on both
Union Jack as well as as well as
Maverick he had instructed his staff
immediately issue a surrender right
immediately tell them we're surrendering
here because the worst thing we can do
is to actually face off against these
forces because what it does is it
implies guilt right like it wouldn't it
would indicate like yes we launched the
attack and I'll be damned if any is
going to come to Liberia and get me
you're never going to take me alive
right I mean it's it's that kind of
thing right and so ultimately he ends up
basically just surrendering to various
forces that show up here now once he's
taken he's actually brought in by a
combination of different things the
first two are silver Sable and Amy Chen
now these two are particularly important
but only in certain circles in Marvel
Comics so silver Sable runs a group
called The Wild pack which is one part
information brokering and one part
mercenary work so they are guys that
basically travel the world they pick up
people who are supposed to be picked up
by various governmental agencies or
corporations or what have you but
because silver Sable is networked with
so many different organizations and
groups out there she's basically a
person tied into a ton of information so
even if she's not necessarily coming
after you if somebody else is coming
after you they can actually hit up
silver stable and if they're able to
offer the right price she'll give them
the information that they need the other
person that's brought here is Dr Steven
strange now the reason why Steven
strange is here is one because this
story takes place before he died and two
because as most people who are familiar
with Dr Doom and Marvel Comics know Dr
Doom and Doctor Strange have a very
strong history together the most notable
instance of the two of them working
together was when they traveled to
basically the realm of Mephisto they
traveled to hell and the story
triumphant torment in order to free Dr
Doom's mother from from mephista right
to free her soul so it could go to
heaven which they successfully did and
in fact that's something that I want you
to keep in the back of your mind because
we'll talk about that again in this
story but Dr Doom's various mystical
abilities are enough that they can match
the powers of Doctor Doom so if you want
to try some crazy you know Jedi mind
trick mysticism stuff Doctor Doom would
be there to basically bring it to an end
but as we know Doctor Doom has no real
intention of doing that now the irony
behind all this and this is the
important thing to understand based on
the visions that Dr Doom's been getting
which he doesn't really know the origin
of of it and we don't really even know
the origin of it at the moment is that
these Visions indicate somewhere along
the line Dr Doom does something which
ushers in an era of peace all across the
world and literally brings a kind of
Utopia that had never been seen before
and so that's why Dr Doom 1 allows
himself to surrender because he's kind
of curious about where these Visions are
leading but two Kane the Conqueror
suddenly appears inside this ship where
Dr Doom's at and it's one of those
things where literally Kings like I've
seen your future right years from now
you're the magnanimous leader of an
eternally peaceful Earth and it would be
the most preferable Earth for me to
conquer and so that's kind of the on
running theme like Kane the Conqueror
will appear more over the course of the
story and really if anything he kind of
shows up I mean Dr Doom does fight him a
couple times but he shows up more often
than not in order to help Doom because
he's like the things that you're gonna
do are basically going to make the earth
a Utopia but it's also going to make the
Earth weaker and it makes it easier for
me to conquer so like here's some stuff
to help you because in helping you I'm
helping myself right like that's really
what he does for a good chunk of the
story and it's hilarious the times that
he shows up it's funny but one of the
things that Doom says is okay if this
future you see is true and it matches
the visions that I've been having then
free me right like if you want to be
able to conquer the Earth in the future
because of what I'll end up doing then
free me and get me out of here and so
one of the things that they do is they
sabotage the the engines of the vessel
and then they basically Escape now you
guys are probably asking yourself why
don't they just teleport out of it the
reality is when you're dealing with king
marvel plays it fast and loose right if
Kang basically destroyed or or sabotaged
the engines it's because in looking over
all the different timelines it's the
only one where they successfully Escape
that's kind of the undercurrent that
Marvel uses right like King does
everything he does for a particular
reason but the reality is that once this
is done basically King teleports away
and Doctor Doom casts a mysticism in
order to save himself following that he
literally goes underground he Dawns a
kind of mask and hides himself and he
takes off to the city of New York now
when he gets there he basically ends up
encountering what are these sort of
visions of Morgan lafay now these
Visions come in the form of her
appearing on in like Times Square on TV
screens different things like that only
Doctor Doom can see her this is one of
those elements of Marvel Comics that's
really cool Morgan lafay has been around
for an exceedingly long time and in fact
she's been around about the same time as
Merlin in Marvel Comics and the thing
about this is she actually originates
from Atlantis or at least the Atlantean
territories before the gray cataclysm
during the second host when the
celestial showed up and then attacked
the deviants that is to say she's been
around for thousands of years and she's
incredibly powerful she's not the most
powerful person ever but it's kind of a
loose knit family between like her and
Dr Doom and Doctor Strange and like the
Scarlet Witch and brother Voodoo people
like that just these people that
practice like magic and mysticism which
is really weird when you think about it
because like there was a time when
Morgan lafaye and Doctor Doom banged so
that's kind of cool but the thing about
this is that while all that's going on
what you end up having is Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four while it's off
panel he comes to the realization that
if Doctor Doom has actually escaped and
Dr Doom's out there on the lamb then
what they need is someone who's every
bit as intelligent as Doctor Doom
meaning this person is one it like kind
of shares the number one spot for the
smartest person in the Marvel Universe
but is also immensely powerful powerful
enough that they can stand toe-to-toe
with Dr Doom and so what you end up
having is Herbie the robot who's kind of
like the robotic assistant of the
Fantastic Four basically traveling to
Cornell and meeting with Adam Brashear
and bringing Adam Brashear in as a
person that can actually capture Dr Doom
now a lot of people are going to ask the
question how in the world is it that
like blue Marvel is on the same level as
Doctor Doom is this just something
you're making it up Rob I'm not making
this up at all and the reason why I say
that is because there's a point when
blue Marvel is meeting with with Herbie
and you know at that point you know blue
Marvel's like okay so Reed Richards is
finally taking me seriously and Herbie's
like well you were the top available
right like you were just you were the
next best choice which is kind of a
crappy way to put it but then Herbie
also goes on to say you match Dr Doom in
intellect and strength especially since
he's without his powers now the way that
Herbie's drawing this information is
based on the information that Reed
Richards has in his database what that
means is that in Marvel Comics what
Christopher Cantwell is establishing
here that Reed Richards is one well
aware of who Adam Brashear is which is
something that we already knew and then
two looking at Adam Brashear the blue
Marvel top to bottom from his
intelligence to his strength to his
powers and so on Reed is basically
established that blue Marvel is as
intelligent and capable as Doctor Doom
what this means is that blue Marvel
shares the number one spot as the
smartest person in the world with Reed
Richards Doctor Doom and Valeria
Richards right right it's a really cool
moment this is one of those things that
you're probably going to see people
referencing when other folks ask the
question where does blue Marvel reside
in terms of intelligence strength so on
and so forth and so following this what
you end up doing is picking back up with
doom while he's traveling with Morgan
lafay and they travel to meet a guy
called the witness now this is the one
and only appearance of the witness at
least in this form that I'm aware of in
Marvel Comics but the idea behind this
guy is he can basically look into the
eyes of another person and then see
exactly what their future is and what
the witness says is that Dr Doom is
going to die and it's the saddest day on
Earth is absolutely beautiful but we
don't really find out exactly how this
death happens but what it does seem to
do is kind of fall in line with the
visions that Dr Doom's been having where
he becomes this person that literally
saves the world that it would be a
tragic and sad day because the world
would have lost somebody's significant
to them the kicker is that before any of
this goes down and any other questions
can be asked Dr Doom is killed on the
spot and he's actually assassinated and
the person who takes him out is none
other than task master Tony Masters I
told you this story gets amazing now
again in this moment what ends up
happening is because Dr Doom is by all
standards the measurement dead he wakes
up in hell he wakes up in the realm of
Mephisto and traveling there he
basically Dawns this kind of Hell armor
which I gotta tell you guys is probably
the second most badass doctor dudes ever
looked the only thing better than this
was when he was God King Doom so he
basically had his normal outfit but it
was all white which was dope and I'm
surprised no one's cosplayed as God King
Doom at any Comic Cons it kind of
astounds me but this looks dope oh my
God like it looks so obese but what ends
up happening is Doctor Doom comes face
to face with Mephisto now the thing
about this is Doctor Doom tells him
right off the bat I'm not supposed to be
here and the response of Mephisto is
that's what they all say but I'm glad to
have your your soul now and forever and
Doctor Doom immediately attacks Mephisto
now here's the thing to understand about
Mephisto right this guy is a misnomer
when it comes to how powerful the Fisto
is with with Mephisto himself he is at
the peak of his power when he's in his
own realm but he's not indestructible
and he's not Unstoppable but the thing
about this is that Doctor Doom is
immensely powerful the reality here is
Doctor Doom's not powerful enough to
overcome Mephisto to beat him in his own
realm like this and so what kind of goes
on here is a bit of bouncing back and
forth where Mephisto starts playing
games with Dr Doom now one of the other
things that I want to establish here is
really kind of more of a background of
what's taking place is that you do have
the kingdom of latviria where Doctor
Doom normally resides what you have next
to it is a place called simcaria and
socari has kind of been a war-torn place
for quite some time only recently has it
actually established any measure of an
organized government and so what's going
on here is that simcaria is actually
actually organizing battle formations
and they're in the process of trying to
conquer Liberia while Dr Doom is not
there so that's an important plot point
to keep in mind again we're not going to
be talking a lot about that but we will
talk about it at the end because it does
become incredibly important at the end
of this but the thing about this kind of
focusing on the Here and Now what
Mephisto does is he tells Dr Doom if you
can convince Valeria that you deserve to
live then you can return to your life
now here's the thing Valeria there's two
different ones there's Valeria Richards
who's the daughter of Reed Richards and
then there's a different Valeria so no
we're not talking about you know Valeria
Richards right this 11 year old kid that
Dr Doom was in love with that's weird
right that's weird and creepy and really
really gross Valeria is a character
who's exceedingly old school in Marvel
Comics and in fact she goes all the way
back to Marvel Superheroes number 20 in
1969 Valeria was a person who lived in
the same camp that Dr Doom did when he
was a little kid they were basically you
know they they kind of fell in love as
teenagers as much as anybody could but
it's not Dr Doom became consumed by
Vengeance and power Valeria basically
left him behind right she just didn't
want to be a part of that life and as a
result of that she eventually fled Dr
Doom caught up to her and basically
convinced her that he was going to leave
all that Madness behind and all he
wanted was her love and a life and so
she ultimately bought into it what was
really going on and probably one of the
most just amazing stories that Mark raid
ever wrote In The Fantastic Four back in
volume three back in 2003 the idea here
is that what Dr Doom had done is he had
actually tricked Valeria and he
effectively sold her soul behind her
back so that he could attain mystical
armor right enhance his powers and so
when that happened her soul was sent to
the realm of Mephisto it was a pretty
shady thing to do and that's why
Mephisto makes this claim if you can
convince the only woman in the world who
ever loved you that you betrayed her
that you deserve life then I will give
it to you and that's the crazy thing is
Victor Von Doom tries to do it any even
tries to rationalize his actions no no I
needed that because I'm going to make
the world a better place I'm going to
make the world a way more interesting
place your your soul right Eternal
damnation for you that was a sacrifice I
was willing to make in order to make
that happen right the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few the
reality here is he's not really
apologetic for it and so in spewing all
this stuff about everything he's seen
suddenly you end up having Valeria that
transforms into a demon really in like
really Mephisto this kind of been
impersonating her and then like really
tormenting Dr Doom and it's like I've
seen this life that you say you've seen
Doctor Doom I see how you save
everything and so on and so forth you're
never going to attain it that's going to
be your damnation here right your
eternal torment is going to be that you
know without a shadow of a doubt that
your one dream in this world actually
comes true that you become this leader
of this Earth You Lead it into Utopia
you become everything that you believe
yourself to be and you're never going to
be able to attain it that that's going
to be your health and so literally a
fight breaks out between the two and
it's pretty knock down drag out but in
the middle of all this mistress death
appears and is like done this fight's
over right he will return to his life
Mephisto now here's the thing even
Mephisto himself regardless of any level
his level of power he has is not stupid
enough to fight mistress death She's the
literal living embodiment of death all
she has to do is will it and Mephisto
ceases to exist that's it I mean that's
literally what you're talking about here
so not even he is stupid enough to
invoke her ire and the funny thing about
this is that where Dr Doom asks right
like are you doing this so that I can
truly go back to Earth and become the
person that saves him and her response
is no it's because you will become my
greatest servant of all you will bring a
level of death and destruction that the
world has never seen it's a crazy thing
because what ends up happening is that
after this whole circumstance arrives or
it really ends that Doctor Doom wakes up
in the home of Morgan lafay who had
taken his body back to her apartment and
of course the two of them are joined by
uh by Blue Marvel now as soon as Dr Doom
sees Adam Brashear he immediately fires
on him and gets him out of there because
Doctor Doom knows how powerful Adam
Brashear is he knows how capable he is
and if a true knockdown drag out fight
between the two happens that given his
current circumstance it's highly
unlikely that Dr Doom will be able to
overpower Adam Brashear and basically
keep him from from being arrested right
so that's why he literally sends him
flying in the moment to sort of get him
out of the way at that point yet again K
the Conqueror pops up
Kane the Conqueror appears and it's one
of those things where it's kind of an
information brokering right at that
point doctor Doom's like okay King I
need you to Rattle your brain I need you
to tell me what timelines there are
where I was successfully killed in this
moment Here and Now not five days ago
right not 50 minutes ago if this moment
right now right I need to know who it
was that killed me and the response of
King is it was Tasman master and he was
hired by Advanced idea mechanics and so
what literally ends up happening here is
Dr Doom finds the base of advanced idea
mechanics right he literally breaks in
he steals their weapons and starts
shooting the place up he kills everyone
right he does he like every single
soldier they have they all die now
here's the thing I had previously stated
that Dr Doom without his powers is
basically useless I was wrong right I
was 100 wrong unlike most people on the
internet I can admit when I'm wrong when
I'm when I think I'm wrong unfortunately
I usually never think I'm wrong so I
usually never admit when I am wrong just
kidding but here's one of the things
right I never really considered Doctor
Doom to be capable when he didn't have
his arms and Armament this dude's a
beast man this guy's rolling through
here with just with just the biggest gun
I've ever seen killing everyone he sees
right just overpowering them all he
duplicates himself several times over
and all those different forces right all
those different versions of himself
start attacking all the these different
soldiers so we still use those powers to
a degree but at the end of the day it
comes down to him and Taskmaster now
this is when you really get to see what
Dr Doom is capable of I never believed
he was good when it came to hand-to-hand
combat mostly because you never really
see him doing hand-to-hand combat it's
always like you know I'm Dr Doom and
magical spells and just badassery all
over the place that's usually all you
ever see but seeing him facing off
against Taskmaster like this and
overcoming Tony Masters is impressive as
hell right it's a pretty pretty cool
thing because remember when you're
fighting against Taskmaster you're not
just fighting Tony Masters you're
fighting everyone Tony Masters has ever
fought right so you're fighting Captain
America Spider-Man Deadpool Wolverine
like all these different characters
because this is a Rolodex he just pulls
those fighting styles out and depending
on the circumstance especially when he
was fighting black panther he actually
merged all those fighting styles into
one to where he would punch like Captain
America but he would Dodge like
Spider-Man and he would kick like
Deadpool it was cool man it was it was
one of the coolest things just some
amazing moments that you see in Marvel
Comics and so once Dr Doom gets the
upper hand on Taskmaster knowing that
taskmaster's mission was quote unquote
finished with Dr Doom the next thing he
wants to know is who are you supposed to
go after next right because he literally
asked him who hired Advanced idea
mechanics to kill me right that's what I
want to know who hired them to take me
out who hired you to take me out and
where he initially won't give that
explanation the reality here is Doctor
Doom's smart enough to know that if
Taskmaster is going after Doctor Doom
then Taskmaster is also going after
people associated with Dr Doom and so
that's when he's like I want to know who
this is who is it you're supposed to go
after next and that's when he says it's
for Xena right it's a woman named for
Xena and at that moment Doctor Doom
basically ends up realizing there's a
much bigger thing going on here and
immediately goes after that chick right
immediately goes after for Xena now the
other thing that takes place here is
kind of working his ranks up right
basically continuing to take out
Taskmaster as well as what seemingly the
rest of advanced idea mechanics he's met
by the arrival of Modoc now Modoc
doesn't really offer much of the way of
a challenge here for Dr Doom he kind of
does but he kind of doesn't he tries to
shoot him with like a mental blast Dr
Doom has the shield of Taskmaster and
his sword he just stabs Modoc in the
chest but this killing is also a long
time coming because remember Modoc was
part of Intelligentsia which was the
organization that stripped Doctor Doom
of his intelligence if you're not
familiar with that storyline we're
actually covering it right now in my
videos on Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic
Four so we'll post a link to that video
down in the playlist but in the midst of
all this you end up picking up on
Liberty Island now Liberty Island is a
place that has these kind of weather
stations that are being created or being
used by this woman named for Xena and
the idea behind this is it's basically
an attempt even if only in a smaller
localized space to basically control
weather in Marvel Comics that kind of
stuff happens all the time it's not
really a new thing it's not really
Landmark it's just something that
Christopher cantwell's throwing in here
to show what she's doing but in the
midst of all this one of the things that
we learned is she is from latviria and
we know this because there are
discussion does it take place between
her and the people around her where they
ask questions like you know is Doctor
Doom really an effective leader you know
is it a good thing that he's gone that
kind of stuff and she's like understand
right the law of sedition and rendition
those individuals who speak ill of
latviria and its leader especially
Liberian citizens will literally be
tossed in some kind of a re-education
camp I don't want to be one of those
guys so I'm going to go back to doing
what I was doing right that kind of a
thing it's just kind of bred into them
in terms of how they function the other
part of this here is that while you do
have Doctor Doom in a library who's
basically reading up on for Xena the
reason why this name is so significant
comes when he's visited by Kane the
Conqueror yet again and when when the
the two of them really start talking is
Doctor Doom saying in these visions that
I had the woman that I end up marrying
is for Xena like that's the person that
I end up marrying and that I end up
having a life with so the reality is if
she's a target of advanced idea
mechanics and they're looking to kill
her by using Taskmaster or somebody I've
got to find a way to keep her alive
she's supposed to end up becoming my
wife and so this is a really significant
moment here and there's actually history
between Doctor Doom and for Cena
indirectly and the reason why this
happens is because you do have a little
bit of a skirmish that takes place
between Dr Doom and Kane the Conqueror
but the significance of this really
comes in the form of the fact that when
Dr Doom ends up visiting for Xena she
initially rebukes him right I mean at
first she's kind of like oh my God it's
Lord Doctor Doom you know that kind of a
thing but once the veil goes away and he
tells her just address me like a regular
person she doesn't like him and in fact
she hates him because he tells her like
I've had visions and you and I are
supposed to get married which is one way
to propose right just like run up on a
random chick hey random woman over there
I've had Visions we're supposed to get
married uh you want to get hitched right
that's not gonna work
but the reason why for Xena hates Doctor
Doom is because there was a point during
doomor when Dr Doom had invaded wakanda
and stole its vibranium that a
journalist in Liberia had spoken out
against Dr Doom because of that and what
Dr Doom had done is he had jailed that
guy basically for forced Edition right
for speaking ill of vladviria and of
Doctor Doom and that guy is still
serving a prison sentence that guy is
the father of farsina and that's why she
hates Dr Doom because the guy was just
doing his job and the price he paid is
is basically a life of imprisonment and
even Dr Doom goes as far as to say I
should have had your father executed for
what he did just be happy in the fact
that I didn't and I was feeling
particularly generous now that's the
most Doctor Doom thing to say to be
honest with you but in the midst of all
this a couple things happen the first is
that you basically have the arrival of
Adam Brashear alongside Herbie and then
you have the arrival of silver Sable and
Victorious now I've kind of held off on
talking about them up to this point the
way things that played out with their
characters is that Victorious was kind
of like the second in command to Doctor
Doom whenever he's not in Liberia she's
the one who runs the show and so where
you basically had the some Koreans who
were attempting to invade latviria
successfully did so and then took over
the country that Victorious was
basically ousted but the other part of
this is that silver Sable being as smart
as she is had realized something else is
going on here and she was actually being
used and so she and Victorious work
together to try to find Doctor Doom so
they could basically put all their
information together and figure out what
the bigger picture is now of course blue
Marvel being here is just for the
purpose of trying to you know to grab
Doctor Doom and it's really an amazing
moment because a fight breaks out
between the two and Adam Brashear holds
his own against Doctor Doom and that's
one of the things that I hope you notice
here in terms of Doctor Doom facing off
against uh against Blue Marvel it's
really him just trying to hold off the
power of Adam Brashear and this is due
to the fact that in this moment Doctor
Doom is not as powerful as Adam Brashear
it's a pretty cool moment right it's a
pretty cool and badass thing we're
literally blue Marvel is more powerful
than Dr Doom In This Moment now of
course yet again Kay the Conqueror shows
up
I told you he would show up at like the
funniest moments and at the most
inopportune times what's really cool
though is that this is an exceedingly
opportune time he shows up here with
just this insane weapon and it's like
okay Doctor Doom this is for you because
remember you gotta live so that you can
make the world easier to conquer for me
like I told you that's his whole
motivation is showing up here strictly
for that and in fact what you end up
having is Adam Brashear who immediately
attacks Kane the Conqueror because Kane
the Conqueror destroys Herbie and so in
that moment Adam Brashear like the blue
Marvel kills Kane the Conqueror right he
kills him on the spot just incinerates
that guy and that's when Dr Doom's like
okay yeah we gotta get out of here like
we gotta find a way to bail the other
part of this though is that no one's
prepared for what comes next because
what happens here is that with Kane the
Conqueror it wasn't simply just a weapon
in that he gave Doctor Doom what he also
gave him was an advanced suit of armor
from his own timeline right from Kang's
own timeline and doing that what it does
is it restores Victor Von Doom back to
his full power he's got the full run of
his technology combined with his
mysticism and advanced Weaponry from
Kane the Conqueror blue Marble's like
look here's the thing Doom we have to
put these grievances aside this black
hole is going to emerge everything's
going nuts with the antleon collider we
have to do something and the response of
Doctor Doom is no like I'm not going to
do that I'm going to go home and I'm
gonna take care of my country Reed
Richards wanted to be the one to run the
show that let Reid Richards run the show
and if the entirety of the project goes
awry and a black hole Singularity opens
at the Moon I will deal with it and I
will take care of it but I will take
care of it because I'm better than he is
but I want the world to know that Reed
Richards is a failure I want the world
to know that he's nowhere near as
capable as I am literally Doctor Doom is
willing to potentially see the the Earth
destroyed just to make Reed Richards
look bad but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
Bruce